Programming Throwdown, Episode 189, Agentic Loops. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everyone, how's it going? Let me adjust my microphone here a little bit. So we should talk about programming. So, you know, I have been, for the first time since I was probably like nine years old, I have not coded for a number of days. And I was thinking a lot about this.
Programming Throwdown，第189期，Agentic Loops（代理循环）。开始吧，Jason。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？让我稍微调整一下麦克风。我们应该聊聊编程。你知道，我大概从九岁起，第一次有这么多天没写代码了。我一直在思考这个问题。
I mean, you know, it's like ever since I was, even before a teenager, I was constantly writing programs on the computer. You know, he started, I don't know if you started with Basic, but I used to do a whole bunch of stuff in Basic. I made like, Choose Your Own Adventure in Basic and a whole bunch of things on the Commodore. And then I went from Basic to, I used Basic for a very long time. I think I went straight from basic to C++, which was terrifying. I definitely like nothing worked for a really long time.
我的意思是，你知道，甚至在我十几岁之前，我就一直在电脑上写程序。你知道，他开始的时候，我不知道你是不是从Basic开始的，但我以前在Basic上做过很多事情。我在Basic上做过类似“选择你自己的冒险”游戏，还在Commodore上做过很多东西。然后我从Basic转到……我用Basic用了很长时间。我想我是直接从Basic转到C++的，那真是太可怕了。很长一段时间里，我什么都做不成。
And I've just been coding ever since. And the weird thing is I've built so many more things. Like my, my, the things that I've built, my build rate or my efficiency or my progress is like super, super high. But all of it is in English. And it's almost at the point. where I don't even really look at the code except for very specific things that I'm trying to find and even that is starting to dwindle.
从那以后我就一直在写代码。奇怪的是，我构建的东西比以前多多了。比如我构建的东西，我的构建速度、效率或进度都非常非常高。但所有这些都是用英语完成的。甚至到了这种程度：除了我试图寻找的非常具体的东西之外，我几乎都不怎么看代码了，而且即使是那样，这种情况也开始减少。
And it's just such a weird feeling. I mean, even the premise of the show is kind of learning every language. And now it's like everything you just code in English or in plain language. You could even code it in whatever language you're most familiar with by typing whatever that is into the DLM.
这真是一种奇怪的感觉。我的意思是，这个节目的前提本来就是学习每一种语言。而现在，一切都只是用英语或普通语言编写。你甚至可以通过在DLM中输入你最熟悉的任何语言来编写代码。
it's really starting to hit me that that coding and plain language is like really probably here to stay. It's kind of wild. Yeah, it is a bit of a mind bend. I mean, I think this is getting to the point where
我真的开始意识到，用普通语言编程可能真的会成为常态。这有点疯狂。是的，这确实有点让人难以接受。我的意思是，我认为这已经到了……
I mean, especially with the framing of it's, people say that a lot. Like, it's the worst it's ever going to be. Like, this is the, there's no reason to believe it would be a rest. Yeah. I guess like if we, somehow ban all GPUs or AI?
我的意思是，特别是考虑到这种框架，人们经常这么说。就像，这是它有史以来最糟糕的时候。就像，没有理由相信它会是休息。是的。我想如果我们以某种方式禁止所有GPU或AI呢？
Isn't that the Dune thing? They have a big war because, anyways, AI is banned. I don't think that's a real. I doubt it's going to happen. So, yeah, you're right, though. Like, it totally changes the way you approach things. And I think there's various people have lots of opinions on it. And, you know, I don't think we should get into all of them.
那不是《沙丘》里的情节吗？他们发生了一场大战，因为，无论如何，AI被禁止了。我不认为那是真的。我怀疑这不会发生。所以，是的，你是对的。它完全改变了你处理事情的方式。我认为不同的人对此有很多看法。而且，你知道，我不认为我们应该深入探讨所有这些。
But one of the ones that you hear is like, oh, it can make bad code or it can make mistakes. And I'm just like, have you worked with programmers? Like, have you looked at your own code? Exactly. Have you looked at Mike? Like, how many times have I found a stupid, just like off by one error or just like, like, yeah, I did all the time. Like, there's this weird thing that like, I don't know,
但你听到的一种说法是，哦，它会写出糟糕的代码或者会犯错。我只是想说，你和程序员一起工作过吗？你看过你自己的代码吗？完全正确。你看过Mike的代码吗？我发现过多少次愚蠢的错误，比如差一错误，或者只是……是的，我一直都在做。有一种奇怪的事情，就像，我不知道，
somehow we were infallible or people were infallible. And I'm not saying like good engineers, bad. Like, I'm just saying random people. Like, everybody makes mistakes. And there's a lot of people I've read code from where it's clear like, I'd have preferred to read the LLM code than what they wrote. So yeah, it's a bit of an interesting transition time. And I think we'll be talking about for a little while,
不知何故我们是不会犯错的，或者人们是不会犯错的。我不是说优秀的工程师很糟糕，我只是说随便什么人。每个人都会犯错。我读过很多人的代码，很明显，我宁愿读LLM写的代码，也不愿读他们写的。所以，是的，这是一个有趣的过渡时期。我想我们会讨论一段时间，
but it definitely feels like there's been a knee in the curve or a change or some threshold has been reached where it's no longer like, oh, it's the, that was a chess and humans, right? The original idea is the chess would help the humans. Then it's like, now the humans are really holding the chess engines back. And so now like modern ones, there's like it is much better to use a chess engine directly than to try to do some. cooperation. And human computer interop is not advantageous.
但这确实感觉像是曲线出现了一个转折点，或者发生了一些变化，或者达到了某个阈值，不再是像，哦，那是国际象棋和人类，对吧？最初的想法是国际象棋会帮助人类。然后现在就像，人类真的在拖国际象棋引擎的后腿。所以现在，现代的引擎，直接使用国际象棋引擎比尝试进行某种合作要好得多。人机交互不再具有优势。
And I feel that's not there yet, but it kind of feels like we're on that journey. There are definitely people who can work with the AI better and giving instructions because we're not going to get into a free will discussion. But like, you know, having the AI
我觉得还没到那一步，但感觉我们正走在那条路上。确实有些人能更好地与AI合作并给出指令，因为我们不会进入自由意志的讨论。但是，你知道，让AI
puts something to do is still something that seems to be in the human domain. But, you know, certainly the tactical open the code editor, debug the code, like, yeah, I'm not sure how much longer that's going to be a thing. And I wonder what like gets lost a little. Like, you know, we can talk about it, but even one of the news articles I have this time, there's definitely things that I've framed in a certain way. We'll say at least in today's AI that helps it. It's like, I want you to take this approach or I want you to use this technique or I want you to do this thing. And I don't have to write the code for it, but I needed to know when and what I was asking for. Again, maybe that. It's just because of limitations of today. But certainly, you know, it has come up in modern, you know, usage. So we'll see where it goes, where the human computer interop boundary ends up being.
做某事似乎仍然在人类的领域内。但是，你知道，当然，打开代码编辑器、调试代码这些战术性的工作，是的，我不确定这还能持续多久。我很好奇什么会稍微丢失一点。就像，你知道，我们可以谈谈它，但即使是我这次准备的新闻文章之一，也确实有些东西是我以某种方式构建的。我们至少在今天的AI中说，它有帮助。就像，我希望你采取这种方法，或者我希望你使用这种技术，或者我希望你做这件事。我不必为此编写代码，但我需要知道什么时候以及我在要求什么。再说一次，也许这只是因为今天的局限性。但当然，你知道，它确实出现在现代的使用中。所以我们将看看它会走向何方，人机交互的边界最终会在哪里。
But yeah, it is crazy to do so much time, like typing text to get what you want. Yeah. I mean, now here's the flip side is I've been, the word I was looking for was productive. I've been orders, probably at least in order. of magnitude more productive, at least, if not more. So I'll give you like a number of examples. So I run this open source thing called MAME Hub, and it's basically a network layer built into this arcade emulator.
但确实，花这么多时间输入文本来得到你想要的东西真是太疯狂了。是的。我的意思是，现在的另一面是，我一直在……我正在寻找的词是“高效”。我的生产力至少提高了一个数量级，如果不是更多的话。所以我给你举几个例子。我运行一个叫MAME Hub的开源项目，它基本上是内置在这个街机模拟器中的网络层。
So if you and I wanted to play Pac-Man together, Pac-Man is a bad example, but was that 1944, that game where you're an airplane? Yeah, 1843. Yeah, 43, yeah. So if we wanted to play one of these, arcade games together. You live in Florida, I live in Texas. You can use MAME Hub. We'd fire it up. And it basically plays the emulator. It only works for emulators that are deterministic, right? But it plays the emulator. And when you press up, it actually cues that up command in the future for both of us.
所以如果你和我想一起玩《吃豆人》，《吃豆人》是个坏例子，但那是《1944》吗，那个你开飞机的游戏？是的，1843。是的，43，是的。所以如果我们想一起玩这些街机游戏。你住在佛罗里达，我住在德克萨斯。你可以使用MAME Hub。我们启动它。它基本上运行模拟器。它只适用于确定性的模拟器，对吧？但它运行模拟器。当你按下向上键时，它实际上会为我们俩在未来排队那个向上命令。
And how long, how far ahead in the future it queues that command is based on, you know, an estimate of our latency. So I try to fit, I try to fit our latency to a distribution and then pick the upper confidence bound of that distribution. It's like 99.7
而它在未来排队那个命令的时间有多长，取决于我们延迟的估计。所以我尝试将我们的延迟拟合到一个分布中，然后选择该分布的上限置信区间。就像99.7%
of the packets arrive on time. And, you know, some tiny percent of the packets don't. And when it doesn't arrive on time, we both have to wait. So if you, so if you say in the future, my joystick looks like this
的数据包准时到达。而且，你知道，一小部分数据包没有。当它没有准时到达时，我们俩都必须等待。所以如果你说在未来，我的操纵杆看起来像这样，
and I don't get that future that I have to wait for it and then you're also having to wait, et cetera. So that's the premise behind MAMEHub. It uses some statistics to figure out how much to schedule those joystick updates so that we both get them and we can play the game
而我没有得到那个未来，我就必须等待它，然后你也必须等待，等等。所以这就是MAMEHub背后的前提。它使用一些统计数据来计算如何调度那些操纵杆更新，以便我们俩都能收到它们，并且我们可以玩游戏，
and it runs the same on both of our computers. So that's MAMEHub. And I used to spend a ton of time just rebasing it, you know, because it's a fork of MAME. It's literally a fork of the MAMEGit project. And, you know, they're making a Zembrising zillion changes. And every few years or so, I would bite the bullet. You know, people would ask for it on
而且它在我们两台电脑上运行的效果是一样的。这就是MAMEHub。我过去花大量时间重新设置它，你知道，因为它是MAME的一个分支。它实际上是MAME Git项目的一个分支。而且，你知道，他们正在进行大量的更改。每隔几年左右，我就会咬牙切齿地去做。你知道，人们会在我们的Discord上要求它，我就会咬牙切齿地去重新设置它。这总是一场灾难，对吧？因为我没有把它分解得很好。所以现在我只是有一个Git作业。我只是在GitHub中有一个使用Copilot来重新设置它的动作。当有冲突时，无论是否有冲突，它甚至会玩游戏并确保游戏正常运行。所以这就是我告诉LLM去构建一些GitHub动作来完成的事情。同样地，哦，这里有一个更好的例子。所以这个播客，你们现在正在听的这个，运行在大量的软件上，对吧？我们有Assembly AI来生成转录。我们使用
our Discord, and I'd bite the bullet, and I would rebase it. And it'd always be a toll disaster, right? Because I didn't really have it factored out, maybe as good as I could have. So now I just have a Git job. I just have like an action in GitHub that uses copilot to rebase it. And when there's conflicts, whether there's conflicts or not, it like even plays a game and make sure that the game works. And so that's something that, you know, I told an LLM to go build some GitHub action to go do that. And so similarly, oh, here's an even better example. So this podcast, what you all are listening to right now runs on a ton of software, right? We have assembly AI for generating the transcripts. We use
我们有Transistor来实际托管网站等等。有了AI，我基本上把所有这些都内部化了。我说，嘿，顺便说一下，Assembly AI，太棒了。他们为我们提供了非凡的服务。如果你需要转录某些东西，而你不想让AI来做，问
we have a transistor for actually hosting the site and all of that. And with AI, I just basically brought all of that in-house. I said, hey, you know, and by the way, Assembly AI, amazing. They've given us phenomenal service. If you need to transcribe something and you don't want to ask AI to do it, ask
这些人来做，他们非常出色。所以这不是针对他们或多年来帮助我们的任何人的攻击。但我基本上去找了一个AI，我说，嘿，这是可以做转录的系统。去互联网上，找一些开源模型，生成一些转录，并继续工作，直到你的转录看起来像他们的转录。这花了一些时间，但AI最终做到了。所以我的观点是，你知道，我觉得我构建的东西比以往任何时候都多，但我不是在用代码编程。所以我认为我们正在做的是用普通语言编程。我认为这才是真正的术语。
these people to do it, they're phenomenal. So this is the slide against them or any of these people who have helped us so much over the years. But I basically went to an AI and I said, hey, here's the system that can do transcripts. Go on the internet, find some open source models, generate some transcripts, and keep working until your transcripts look like their transcripts. And it took a while, but AI eventually did that. So my point is, you know, I feel like I'm building way more than ever, but I'm not coding in code. And so I think what we're doing is coding in plain language. I think that's really the terminology.
所以看起来未来的关键将是如何更有效地用普通语言编程，以及我们如何构建这些工具，使所有这些尽可能流畅。这就是我们这期节目要讨论的内容。这甚至可能是，你知道，一段时间内最重要的事情。说到重要的事情，也许是时候进入我们的新闻部分了，我想你拿到了第一个，我不想剧透，但是
And so it seems like the feature is going to be how do we code in plain language more effectively and how do we build these harnesses that, that, you know, kind of make all of that as fluid as possible. So that's what we're going to talk about this show. That might even be, you know, the most important thing for a while. Talking about important things, maybe it's time to move. to our news section and I think you got the first I don't want to spoil it but but
你先来。是的，我的意思是，这是突发新闻，我相信没人听说过，但内存价格失控了，内存价格完全失控了，我认为它们会继续失控。我实际上认为它们会变得更
you take it first. Yeah I mean this is a late breaking news I'm sure nobody's heard of this but RAM is out of control the RAM prices are totally out of control I think they're going to keep becoming out of control I actually think they're going to get a lot
糟糕。所以这只是……让我保持关注。我的意思是，这是一篇Tom's Hardware的文章，我相信你可以找到很多其他的，但如果你在对自己说，我现在不买电脑，
worse and and so this is just let me keep an eye I mean this is a Tom's Hardware article I'm sure you can find plenty of others, but if you are, if you're saying to yourself, I'm not going to buy a computer now
因为内存价格真的很高。你可能不得不这样做，咬牙买下那台电脑。你知道，我只是觉得内存短缺将持续数年，而且在好转之前会变得更糟。所以如果你
because the RAM prices are really high. You might have to just do that, just bite the bullet and get the computer. You know, I just feel like the RAM shortage is going to take years, and it's not going to, it's going to get a lot worse before it gets better. So if you,
有一台电脑需要购买，或者需要升级，或者组装硬件什么的，你知道，我真的建议现在就做，锁定价格，尽管看起来价格很高，现在就锁定它。是的，
if you have a computer you need to buy or an upgrade, you make your hardware or something, you know, I really suggest kind of doing it now, locking in, even though it looks like a high price, locking it in now. Yeah,
听起来他们说所有的内存都被预订了，大概未来一年，甚至价格更高。是的，是的，我没有买Steam Deck，尽管我很想要一个，
it sounds like they're saying all of the RAM is spoken for for like the next year, over year at, you know, even higher prices. Yeah, yeah, I didn't buy a Steam deck as much as I wanted one
因为我总是……实际上，这有点悲伤，但我大概每季度去一次Steam Deck页面，我离购买它非常近，我想，你知道，如果我这样做，我会玩比我现在正在玩的更多的游戏，
because I always, I actually, this is kind of sad, but I went to the Steam Deck page probably once a quarter and I got so close to buying it and I was like, you know, if I do that, I'll play even more games that I'm already playing
所以我没有下手，现在它的价格是原来的两倍。所以我决定Switch对我来说还可以，但如果我想要一个Steam Deck，我不指望它会降价。是的，我确实买了一个，但现在我觉得我应该把它卖掉。哦，
and so I didn't pull the trigger on it and now it's twice the price. So I decided that I'm fine with the Switch but if I wanted a, I don't expect the Steam Deck to come down in price. Yeah, I did get one but now I feel like I should sell it. Oh,
我和你一样，我早就有了一个，但你是对的，我不知道人们怎么以这个价格证明它的合理性，你知道我的意思吗？我肯定，是的，即使在之前它也不一定便宜，但我很享受它，你知道，它很好。我肯定不会从它身上获得当前价格的价值，它太贵了。所以你真的得知道你会把它用到极致，我想。好吧，我不是说它不是……这是一个问题，我的意思是，如果电脑价格翻了三倍并保持在这个水平，那会对你有什么影响？
me and yeah I had one from early on but you're right like I don't know how people are justifying it at the price it's you know what I mean like I I definitely yeah even before it wasn't necessarily cheap but I've I've enjoyed it you know it's been good I definitely wouldn't have gotten the current price value out of it it would have been too expensive so you got a really you know what you're going to use the crap out of it I guess well and I'm not saying it's not here's a question I mean if the price of computers triples and stays that way. How is that going to affect you?
比如，你还会升级你的电脑吗？我的意思是，我觉得在某个时候，如果它坏了，你还是需要升级的，你知道。我的意思是，我认为这取决于，对吧？所以这意味着什么？比如，你需要升级你的电脑。所以对我来说，我的意思是，我认为我有几个选择。首先，你可以订阅游戏流媒体服务。如果你有好的互联网，它们已经变得好多了。
Like, are you still going to upgrade your computer? I mean, I feel like at some point you just kind of need to upgrade if it breaks or, you know. I mean, I think it depends, right? So what does it mean? Like, you need to upgrade your computer. So for me, I mean, I think I have a number of options. So for one, you could just like subscribe to the gaming streaming services. They have gotten a lot better if you have good internet.
有些人会称之为它。但同样，如果它是，不管是什么，我不知道，每月20美元，每月30美元租用一些东西，甚至是你租用自己的电脑并安装在共享时间上的那种，那是我考虑过的一种套利形式，你知道，用于运行一些本地模型。就像我认为我们稍后会讨论的，你可以租用时间和分时。我认为这是一种方式。你知道，我们还有其他像手机更强大的设备。
And some people will call that it. But again, if it's whatever, I don't know, $20 a month, $30 a month to rent something, even one of the ones where you rent your own computer and install it on shared time. Like, that's a form of arbitrage I've considered, you know, for running some of the local models. Like I think we'll talk about a little later, like you could rent time and timeshare. And I think that's one way. You know, also we have also other like phones are more powerful.
所以有些事情可以……这并不理想。这只是在手机上玩游戏，你知道，游戏机。如果你有游戏机，你知道，坚持使用旧游戏机并玩你以前想玩的游戏。我认为受伤害最大的人是那些想要最新视频游戏最高性能的人。谢天谢地，我只是不在那场竞赛中。所以，你知道，对我来说，除非有什么东西直接坏了，你知道，我可能和你一样，可能有很多电子产品。如果必须的话，我们可以在家庭成员之间共享笔记本电脑什么的。
So some stuff can. It's not ideal. It's just be done on gaming on a phone, you know, consoles. if you're having a console, you know, sticking with older consoles and playing games you just want to play before. I think the people are going to get hurt the most of people like want the max performance on the latest video games. Thankfully, I just not in that race. So, you know, for me, short of like something straight up breaking, you know, I'm probably like you, probably have like lots of electronics. We could share between members of the family laptops or something if we had to.
但是，你知道，在某个时候，是的，如果需要的话，你还是会妥协并购买它。但我认为，它坏了、我什么都没有、我需要购买，这和我有东西但比我想要的要差，这两者之间是有区别的。你知道我的意思吗？就像两者的需求略有不同。所以对我来说，它变成了关于那个。但我确实想升级内存，但我等得太久了。那个窗口已经关闭了。我想那不会发生了。你知道，在这一点上升级内存，系统的其余部分基本上是免费的。这是真的，买全新的硬盘，特别是SSD和NVMe也疯了。
But, you know, at some point, yeah, you would just break down and buy it if you needed it. But I think then you have like a, there's a difference between it's broken and I have nothing and I need to acquire a cost. And I have something that is just less than I would want. Like, you know what I'm? Like the demand in both are slightly different. So for me, it becomes about that. But I've certainly wanted to upgrade the RAM and I just waited too long. And like that window is closed. I guess that's not going to happen. You know, at this point upgrading the RAM, the rest of the system is just basically free. like that's true by a whole no hard drives and specifically like SSDs and MVME have also gone nuts
那不仅仅是内存，但如果你尝试购买它，你谈论的是像Steam Deck，我想买一张更大的SD卡，但我没注意，因为每个人都在谈论
that's not just RAM but if you try to buy it you're talking about like the steam deck I wanted to get a bigger SD card and I hadn't paid attention because everyone talks
内存，但即使是SD卡也涨疯了，因为纳米芯片短缺，所以是的，这很疯狂。我想
about RAM but even SD cards have gone through the roof for people the shortage of nan chips so yeah it's pretty wild I think
嗯，是的，我认为现在也是更换手机的好时机，因为同样，手机里有很多内存。我遇到了一个问题，我的手机开始退化了。它大约有五年了。我想，是的，我应该，是时候了。另外，我担心价格会上涨。
um yeah I think it's probably a good time to replace your phone too because again phone has a lot of ram in it. I had an issue where my phone has started to degrade. It's about five years old. And I was like, yeah, I should, it's time. Plus, I was worried about the prices going up.
所以我买了一部手机。它实际上昨天到了。大约两三天前，旧手机上的GPS芯片完全坏了。所以我真的很幸运。我算准了时间，GPS芯片坏了，第二天新手机就到了。但大约有一两天，我的孩子们，这太搞笑了，我们在车里，那个蓝点在城市里到处传送，孩子们觉得这是最有趣的事情，但……是的，我的意思是，即使是手机，如果你的手机用了四五年，你知道，如果你能忍受，现在就买手机，在价格上涨之前。我的下一篇文章不是关于AI的，但它有点关于AI。好吧，这是一篇题为《马里奥遇见帕累托》的文章。这是关于帕累托前沿，即有效前沿。但它是在每个人最喜欢的竞技视频游戏中。好吧，那是谎言。这是我唯一和家人一起竞技玩的游戏，而不是在线玩，因为我没那么厉害。
So I got a phone. I actually arrived yesterday. And about two or three days ago, the GPS chip, like completely failed on my older phone. So I really got super lucky. I timed it where a GPS ship fails. Next day the new phone is there. But there's about a day or two where my kids, I was hilarious that we were we were in the car and the the blue dot was just like teleporting all over the city and uh kids thought that was the funniest thing but but uh yeah i mean even for a phone i would say if you're on like a four or five year old phone you know and you could and you can you can stomach it you know get the phone now before the prices go out my next article is not per se about AI but it's kind of about AI all right so this is an article titled maria
但我的孩子们认为我很厉害，虽然现在不是了，因为他们变得厉害多了。蓝色龟壳是帕累托占优的，对吧？哦，就武器而言。但这基本上是在经历，这实际上是一个非常有趣的事情，即使你不关心马里奥赛车，但设置是你有一些角色。我知道有多少，大概16个角色你可以选择。他们每个人都有一些数量的，你知道，车辆他们
meets Pareto. And this is about the Pareto Frontier, the efficient frontier. But it's in everyone's favorite competitive video game. Okay, that's a lie. It's the only one I play competitively with my family and not online because I'm not that good.
可以坐在里面，你知道，卡丁车或摩托车。他们有一些你可以装上的轮胎，然后在最近的，不是最近的，几乎是最近的马里奥赛车里有一些滑翔装置。我想是《马里奥赛车8豪华版》。每一个都会改变各种参数。还有一些隐藏的参数甚至没有显示出来。所以问题是，你怎么选？答案是没有一个正确的答案。你知道，成长过程中，总是这样，你选这个，这个人或这辆车，或者，你知道，这是你在《麦登橄榄球》中选择的团队，你知道。
But my kids think I'm good, although not anymore because they've gotten a lot better. The Blue Turtle is Pareto dominant, right? Oh, in terms of weapons. But it's basically going through, which is a very actually, you know, an interesting thing, even if you don't care too much about Mario Kart, but the setup is you have some number of characters on. I know how many is like 16 characters you can choose from. Each of them have some number of, you know, vehicles they
答案比那复杂得多。取决于你如何定义。这是软件工程中经常出现的问题，这就是为什么它是一篇有趣的文章。在金融领域也是如此，但你是在优化什么？所以如果你从金融的角度来考虑，买股票更好，还是把钱存进储蓄账户更好？这就像，好吧，你有多关心风险，你有多关心增长？因为，你知道，没有免费的午餐，对吧？
can be in, you know, go cards or motorcycles. They have some kind of tires you can put on and then some sort of like a glider device in the more recent, most recent, no, nearly most recent Mario Kart. I think Mario Kart 8 deluxe. And each one of those changes various parameters. There's also some hidden parameters that even aren't shown. And so the question is like, how do you pick? And the answer is there is no one right answer. You know, growing up, it was always, you pick this, this person or this car, or, you know, this is the team you pick in Madden, you know.
好吧，我想那是偷了另一个金融习语，经济学。但观点是，你可能处于严格更糟糕的位置。所以有些事情你可以用你的钱做，风险更大，预期回报更低，你不应该选择那些事情。就像在马里奥赛车中，虽然没有唯一的最佳答案，但某些组合，取决于你关注什么指标，甚至是所有指标，选择它们都是严格更糟糕的选择，除非你只是在捣乱。我想那不是一个指标。但针对正常指标，你知道，某些组合是严格更糟糕的。所以如果你关心两个变量之间的权衡，
The answer is like more complicated than that. Depends on like how you define. And this is something that comes up a lot in software engineering, which is why it's kind of an interesting article. And also in finance, but like, what are you optimizing for? And so if you think about to spend it in terms of like finance, is it better to buy stocks or better to put your money in a savings account? And it's like, well, how much do you care about risk and how much do you care about, you know, growth? Because, you know, there's no free lunch, right?
比如加速和最高速度，这是非常常见的，那么有些组合不是，是严格劣于其他的。所以观点是，任何生活在某种组合中，不在内部，不劣质的东西，我们称这些东西为帕累托有效或在帕累托前沿上，这意味着它们通常在图表的右侧和上方，对吧？所以沿着所有选择有一条曲线。
Okay, that's stealing another finance idiom, I guess, economics. But the idea is that there are strictly worse positions you can be in. So there are things you could do with your money that are more. risky for less expected payoff and you should not choose those things. Just like in Mario Kart, although there is no singular best answer, there are certain combinations which depending on what metrics or even all the metrics, choosing them is strictly a worse choice unless you're just trolling. I guess that's not a metric. But against the normal metrics, you know, there are certain combinations that are strictly worse. So if you care about, you know, the tradeoff between two variables,
这适用于我们做的很多事情。就像我提到的，权衡你在投资组合中投入什么，你如何在视频游戏中选择角色。你经常听到它出现在LLM模型中。所以LLM模型有各种能力和各种每个Token的价格。这形成了一个有效前沿。所以，你知道，你可能会争论Open AI或Anthropic今天是否有最好的模型。但它们肯定不是最便宜的。
like acceleration and top speed, which are very common ones, then there are combinations which are not, are strictly inferior to other ones. And so the idea is anything that lives for some combination, not in the interior, not inferior, we call those things perido efficient or on the Pareto Frontier, which means they're sort of like normally in the graph to the right and up, right? So there's this curve along all the choices.
所以如果你需要更少，你可以选择更便宜的，有不同的位置。但也有一些地方你可以花同样的钱买到更烂的AI，对吧？所以有一个帕累托前沿。当我们谈论改进时，我们谈论的是推动那个前沿向前发展，移动到一个没有人去过的新位置，并迫使其他人去追赶。所以这是一篇非常有趣、写得很好、有很多酷炫图形的文章。你知道，每个人都喜欢好的视频游戏故事。如果你玩过马里奥赛车，很多人都玩过，你绝对可以读读这个。
and this applies through so many things we do. Like I mentioned, trading off what you put in your investment portfolio, how you choose characters in video games. You hear it a lot coming up about LLM models. So there are LLM models have various abilities and various price per token. And that forms an efficient frontier. So, you know, you may argue whether Open AI or Anthropic today has the best model. But they certainly don't have the cheapest.
但这也是对一个重要概念的介绍。是的，这太酷了。我总是选库巴，现在我才知道那显然被大金刚帕累托占优了。所以。太棒了。是的，去看看吧。
So you can go cheaper if you need less, and there's like a different position. But there are also places you could pay just as much for crappier AI, right? So there is a Pareto Frontier. And when we talk about improvements, we're talking about moving that frontier forward, moving to a new spot that no one has been before and forcing others to play catch up. So a very interesting, well-written, lots of cool graphics. You know, everybody loves a good video game story. If you've played Mario Kart, which lots of people have, you can definitely read this.
是的，这是一个非常重要概念的伟大可视化。我喜欢这个。好吧，我的是Quen 3.8对阵Muse Glimmer。所以很有趣，模型的大小随着时间的推移经历了不同的，你知道，炒作周期。所以你基本上有那些试图构建最大模型的人。所以目前，你知道，这些是，你知道，封闭实验室，然后还有像GLM或像Kimmy K3这样的人，我认为它有一个2.5万亿参数的模型。
but also an introduction to an important concept. Yeah, this is super cool. I always picked a Bowser, and now I'm learning that that was like Pareto-dominated by Donkey Kong, apparently. So. That's awesome. Yeah, check it out.
所以，你知道，至少对于Kimmy来说，如果你想服务Kimmy K3，我认为你需要价值20万美元的设备，最低限度。所以，你知道，它绝对超出了几乎每个人的个人能力范围。对于大多数公司来说也不切实际，除非你认为你真的能服务那个模型，你知道，让它24小时全天候忙碌。现在，另一方面，你有非常小的模型，旨在真正运行在边缘设备上。例如，你有Jemma 4 E2B模型，E2B意味着有效20亿。所以基本上有一个路由器，而不深入细节，有一种路由器决定激活哪些专家和哪些模块。而且，我不知道他们从哪里得到“有效”这个词，但平均而言，你知道，他们激活了大约20亿的权重。
Yeah, this is a great visualization of a really important concept. I love this. All right. Mine is Quinn 3.8 versus Muse Glimmer. So it's interesting, like the sizes of the models have gone through different, you know, like hype cycles over time. So you basically have the people who are trying to build the biggest models. And so currently, you know, these are, you know, the closed labs and then and then people like GLM or like Kimmy K3, which has, I think, a two and a half trillion parameter model.
所以它可以在你的手机上运行，特别是在你量化它之后，你知道，即使有KV缓存等等，你知道，它可以在你的手机上非常舒适地运行。所以出现的是中间的一种甜点，你知道，它太大而无法在你的手机上运行，甚至在入门级机器上。所以想象一台有16GB内存的机器。你知道，这些模型太大而无法在那些机器上运行，但它们足够小，可以在单台高端机器上运行，你知道，消费级高端机器。
And so, you know, so at least for Kimmy, if you wanted to serve Kimmy K3, you would need, I think, like $200,000 worth of equipment minimum. So, you know, it's definitely out of reach for almost everybody on an individual level. And not practical for most companies, unless you think you can really serve that model, you know, keep it busy 24-7. Now, then on the flip side, you have models that are very small that are meant to really run on edge devices. So, for example, you have the Jemma 4 E2B model, and the E2B means effectively 2 billion. So there's basically a router, and without getting too much in the weeds here, there's kind of a router that decides which experts and which modules to activate. and and it's I don't know where they get the word effective from, but on average, you know, they're activating about $2 billion of the weights.
所以想想像MacBook Pro有48GB内存，你知道，或者Windows笔记本电脑有64GB内存等等。所以Muse Glimmer和Quen 3.8都在300亿左右。我想Quen那个是270亿。所以，你知道，正如我所说，如果你有一台高端笔记本电脑或台式机，你可以非常舒适地运行它们。
So that can run on your phone, especially after you quantize it, you know, even with the KV cash and all that, you know, it can run very comfortably on your phone. So what's emerged is kind of this sweet spot in the middle where, you know, it's too big to run on your phone or even on. an entry level machine. So imagine a machine with like 16 gigs of RAM. You know, these models are too big to run on those, but they're small enough to run on a single high-end machine, you know, consumer high-end machine.
而且它们非常非常强大。现在，我自己试过了。我还没有完全达到我在基准测试中人们声称的那些任务的性能水平。所以感觉模型可能并没有完全达到炒作的程度，至少对于Quen来说是这样。
So think like a MacBook Pro is 48 gigs of RAM, you know, or a Windows laptop and 64 gigs of RAM, etc. And so Muse Glimmer and Quinn 3.8 are both around 30 billion. I think the Quinn one is 27. And so, you know, as I said, if you have a high end, your laptop or desktop, you can run those pretty comfortably.
Muse Glimmer，我认为相当不错。我从这些较小模型中注意到的最大事情是，这很有趣，它们不一定在正确的时间调用正确的工具，而且它们也不知道什么时候停止工作。所以它们会工作得太少，或者它们会思考得太久。我发现这真的很迷人，因为如果你仔细想想，什么是更大的模型？好吧，最明显的事情之一是更多的参数，所以更多的事实，对吧？所以如果你说，法国的首都是什么，它说是巴黎，
And they're very, very powerful. Now, I've tried it myself. I haven't quite got the level of performance for the tasks that I'm doing that people are claiming in the benchmarks. So it does feel like maybe the model's quite living up to the hype there, at least for Quinn.
好吧，模型中有一组参数负责知道那个事实。所以有理由认为，你知道，如果你有一个巨大的模型，它知道更多的事实，并且它可以在特定问题上带来更多的事实。这是真的，但看起来批判性思维更好。我不知道是否有人真的，我能想象人们解释这一点的最接近的是Anthropic的这个J-space理论论文，其中模型将问题投影到某个高层空间，然后尝试在该空间中解决它。所以也许更大的模型有更大的空间可以工作。但即使是像浏览网页和做一些相当死记硬背的事情，比如网页上相当简单的事情，甚至孩子在网页上都能做的事情，你知道，比如更改这组作业的日期或这个网站上的某些东西。你知道，较小的模型往往会为此挣扎。所以这只是在常识层面上，存在相关性，我觉得这很有趣。但模型正在变得越来越好。
Use glimmer, I think, is pretty good. The big thing that I've noticed from these smaller models is, and this is kind of interesting, is they don't necessarily call the right tool at the right time, and they also don't really know when to stop working. So they'll work for too little, or they'll think for too long. And I found this really fascinating, like, because if you, think about it, what is a bigger model? Well, one of the most obvious thing that it is is more parameters and so more facts, right? So if you say, what's the capital of France and it says Paris,
这些30B模型绝对比人们一年前在本地运行的9B和12B模型有了巨大、巨大、巨大的改进。所以这绝对是做了大量的改进。我最后想说的是，我认为人们提出的90%的问题都可以由这个30B模型处理。你知道，比如，人们在问ChatGPT什么样的问题？你知道，我怎么煎鸡蛋？昨天我拍了一张孩子们给我们的纸质日程表的照片。我说，你知道，为这个创建一个日历ICS文件。
well, there's some parameters or some set of parameters in the model that are responsible for knowing that fact. And so it stands to reason that, you know, if you have a giant model, it knows a lot more facts and it can bring a lot more facts to bear on a particular problem. And that's true, but it just seems like the critical thinking is better. And I don't know if anyone's really, the closest I can imagine people have come to explaining this is this J-space theory paper from Anthropic where models like project problems into some high-level space and then try and solve it in that space. And so maybe the bigger models have a bigger space to work with. But even things like browsing the web and doing kind of pretty
你知道，所有这些事情30B模型都能做，我有信心。所以一方面，差距是存在的。而且看起来它可能不容易被缩小。另一方面，你不需要更昂贵的模型来处理90%的任务。是的，我同意。我的意思是，这绝对是一个有趣的空间。事实上，它是最有趣的空间之一，因为我看到，我不会，我不知道，我不想过多地谈论个人信仰，
wrote things on the web like pretty easy things that even a child can do on the web, you know, like change the dates on this set of assignments or something on this website. You know, the smaller models will tend to struggle with that. So it's just on the common sense level, there is a correlation there, which I found interesting. But the models are getting better and better.
但我仍然看到这一点，就像，哦，嗨，我们的，你知道，ChatGPT，你知道，Cloud，Gemini应用程序很乐意摄取你的数据。你想分享你的日历、你的健康信息、你的任何东西吗？然后就像，不。你知道，不管怎样。再说一次，我不会进入隐私作为一个对很多人来说是个人的和不同的东西，但本地模型对我来说是一种你可以说，看，我可以这样做的方式。
These 30B models are definitely a huge, huge, huge improvement over the 9 and 12b models that people are running locally a year ago. So it's definitely a ton of improvement made. And I'll just end it by saying, I think 90% of the questions people are asking can be handled by this 30B model. You know, like, what are the kind of questions people are asking, chat TBT? You know, how do I fry an egg? Yesterday I took a picture of my kid's schedule that they gave us on a sheet of paper. And I said, you know, create a calendar ICS file for this.
没有，就像，我在这里做我正在做的事情很好，你知道，但它留在我的电脑上。甚至只是像，嘿，我有一个，你能检查我的纳税申报表并做一个图表，显示我过去几年的有效税率吗？我很想知道那个。但我不会上传。第一，那有很多数据要上传。
You know, all of these things that 30B model could do, I'm confident of it. And so it's like on one hand, the gap is there. And it seems like it might not be easily closed. On the other hand, you don't need the more expensive model for 90% of tasks. Yeah, I agree. I mean, it's definitely an interesting space. In fact, one of like the most interesting spaces, because I saw, I won't, I don't know, I don't want to go too much into like personal beliefs,
第二，就像，我真的不想为了，你知道，谁知道什么原因，发生了什么，而暴露那种程度的细节。现在突然你问，Patrick Wheeler赚多少钱或者什么？然后突然间，就像，哦，我知道，这就是我正在训练的。是的，所以就像，我认为本地模型是重要的事情。如果你还没有尝试过，它绝对值得一试。而且就像你说的，我想，Jason，有很多问题，是的，它只是，
but I still see this just like, oh, hi, our, you know, chat GPT, you know, Cloud, Gemini app is happy to ingest your data. Would you like to share your calendar, your health information, your whatever? And it's like, no. You know, whatever. Again, I'm not going to get into privacy as like a thing that's. personal and different for a lot of people, but local models to me are a way where you can say, look, I can do this.
我的意思是，我猜就像反过来，谷歌搜索，比如，我以前无法搜索的东西或者什么，被超级快地回答了，但我假设它是谷歌正在使用的相对便宜的，你知道，Gemini模型。所以很多那些事情是可以完成的。而且我确实认为专家混合，像你说的那些有效的，
There's not, like, I'm fine doing what I'm doing here, you know, but it's staying on my computer. And even just something like, hey, I have a, can you go through my tax returns and just make a plot of like my effective tax rate over the last few years? I would love to know that. But I'm not uploading. One, that's like a lot of data to upload.
真的很有趣，因为它们给了你从SSD流式传输到内存的机会，如果SSD没有那么贵的话，但就像在推理阶段将数据从磁盘流式传输到内存中。而且总的来说它们意味着什么。但我对你能做到的那种水平感到兴奋，而且速度也很快。就像通常你很快就能得到回应。
And two, like, I don't really want to expose that level of detail for, you know, who knows what reasons, what happens. Now all of a sudden you ask, how much does Patrick Wheeler make or whatever? And then all of a sudden, it's like, oh, I know, that's what I'm like training. Yeah, so it's like, I think local models like important thing. And if you've not tried it, it's definitely worth trying. And like you said, I think, Jason, there's a lot of like questions that, yeah, it just,
而如果你曾经广泛使用过那些其他服务，有时我认为它们只是被限速了。就像有太多人在使用它们。所以回应太慢了。而这里是一个单用户的东西，对吧？就像我想要的时候我就得到回应。是的。所以我试了这两个。
I mean, I guess like to flip it around, Google search, like, things that. I just couldn't search for before or whatever, just get answered super fast by, but I assume it's a relatively cheap, you know, Gemini model that Google is using. And so a lot of those things can be done. And I do think the mixture of experts, the effective ones like you're saying,
我试了Muse Glimmer，我也相当广泛地试了Quen 3.8。我发现，这一直是这些Quen模型的一个问题，它们往往在文本和格式化文本以及正确输出文本方面真的很挣扎。例如，我让它们俩处理同一个任务，涉及创建大量的Markdown内容。我发现的是，Quen 3.8模型，它不会关闭粗体。所以你知道在Markdown中你用双星号来使某物变粗吗？所以它会开始像一个词那样的粗体，但然后它不会关闭粗体，它们会变得非常困惑。你最终要么得到
are really interesting in that they give you opportunity for streaming from like an SSD into RAM if SSDs weren't so expensive as well, but like streaming the data off of disk and interram for like that stage of inference. and just in general what they mean as well. But I'm excited for that level of like what you can do and just speed as well. Like oftentimes you get a response pretty quick.
像大量的粗体内容，要么它会字面上画出两个星号。所以它只是无法尊重Markdown的格式。Muse Glimmer能够尊重它。我注意到的另一件事，个人轶事是，Ollama，我用来服务这些模型的工具，它几乎对任何模型都有MLX模式。就像对于每个模型你可以放dash MLX，如果你在Mac OS机器上，
Whereas if you're if you've ever used one of those other services extensively, sometimes I think they just get throttled. Like there's just too many people using them. And so the responses are just so slow. And here it's a single user thing, right? Like I just get the response when I want it. Yeah. So I tried both of these.
它会使用像MLX，我不知道它是什么，但它是Mac上的一种东西，让它更快地进行这些向量操作。但我后来发现，并且后来我确认了这一点，Ollama做MLX的方式，它们有一种自动将模型转换为MLX的方法，
I tried Muse Glimmer and I tried Quen 3.8 pretty extensively. I found that for, and this has been always a problem with these Quen models, is there tend to really struggle with text and formatting text and outputting text correctly. So for example, I had both of them work on the same task, which involved creating a lot of markdown. content. And what I found is that the Quinn 3.8 model, it wouldn't close the bold. So you know how in Markdown you double asterix to make something bold? So it'll start something bold like a word, but then it won't close the bold and that they'll get real confused. And you'll either end up with
我不认为那是100%可靠的。在这个过程中丢失了一些东西，因为当我比较MLX版本和常规版本时，常规版本好得多。所以我猜所有这些都是为了在高层面上说，这有点像Ender S1 3D打印的日子。你知道，我们超越了像，哦，你必须从零开始构建你自己的3D打印机，而且它可能无法工作，
like a giant amount of bold content or it'll just literally draw the two asterisies. So it just wasn't able to respect the formatting of Markdown. Muse Glimmer was, was able to respect it. The other thing I noticed, personal anecdote is, Olama, which is what I was using to serve these models, it has an MLX mode for almost any model. Like for every model you can put dash MLX, and it will, if you're on a Mac OS machine,
但我们还没有达到像，哦，我买了一个Bamboo，一切都能正常工作。所以我们处于中间的某个地方，这些300亿参数的模型很强大，你可以看到未来就在拐角处，但它还不是那种即插即用的。我支持那个类比。我想你会欣赏那个。好吧。我的下一个有点不协调，我想，和我们到目前为止讨论的很多东西，但没关系，每个人都应该知道SIMD。
and it'll use like MLX, which I'll have no idea what it is, but it's some kind of thing on the Mac that lets it do these vector operations faster. But what I came to find out, and later on I confirm this, is the way Olamma does the MLX, they have some way of automatically converting a model to MLX,
它会使用类似MLX的东西，我不知道那是什么，但它是Mac上的一种能让向量运算更快的工具。但我后来发现并证实了，Ollama使用MLX的方式是，他们有一种自动将模型转换为MLX的方法，
and I don't think that that is, 100% reliable. There's something lost in that process because when I compared the MLX version to the regular version, the regular version was a lot better. So I guess all of this to say at a high level, it's kind of like Ender S1 3D printing days. You know, we're beyond like the, oh, you have to build your own 3D printer from scratch and it probably won't work.
但我认为这并不百分之百可靠。在这个过程中会有所损失，因为当我把MLX版本和常规版本进行对比时，常规版本要好得多。所以我想说的是，从宏观层面来看，这有点像Ender S1 3D打印的早期阶段。你知道，我们已经超越了那种“哦，你必须从零开始组装一台3D打印机，而且它可能还无法工作”的阶段。
but we're not quite at the like, oh, I buy a bamboo and everything just works. So we're somewhere in the middle where these 30 billion parameter models are powerful and you can see the future right around the corner, but it's not just like drop in yet. I'm here for that analogy. I figured you to appreciate that. All right. My next one sort of in Congress, I think with a lot of the stuff we've been talking about so far, but that's okay, is everyone should know SIMD.
但我们还没有达到那种“哦，我买了一台拓竹（Bambu），一切都能直接运行”的程度。所以我们正处于中间地带，这些300亿参数的模型功能强大，你可以看到未来就在眼前，但它还不是那种即插即用的东西。我很喜欢这个类比。我就知道你会欣赏这个。好的，我的下一个观点可能与我们目前讨论的很多内容不太一致，但这没关系，那就是每个人都应该了解SIMD。
So we talked about SIMD a number of episodes ago. Someone's going to be like, oh, it's 100 episodes ago. But I don't think it was. SimD is a single instruction multiple data. And in line with I saying before, this specific example is actually about Zig programming, which I've never done Zig programming. There's some nuance there.
我们在几集之前讨论过 SIMD。有人可能会说，哦，那是 100 集之前的事了。但我觉得没那么久。SIMD 是单指令多数据（Single Instruction Multiple Data）。正如我之前所说，这个具体的例子其实是关于 Zig 编程的，我从来没写过 Zig。这里面有一些细微差别。
But in general, just like I think we talked about in the other show, just walking through like what, what it is and why it's important. I think this is an example where, at least today, it can be difficult to balance, you know, implementation, I'll even say with the LLMs, of doing something one way and then like completely redoing it in another. So when you build a program sort of normally,
但总的来说，就像我们在另一期节目中讨论的那样，只是梳理一下它是什么以及为什么它很重要。我认为这是一个例子，至少在今天，很难平衡实现方式，我甚至会说，对于大语言模型（LLM）来说，用一种方式做某事，然后完全用另一种方式重做，是很难平衡的。所以当你以常规方式构建程序时，
the most common thing is to have an array of structures, right? So you have an array and your array, you put your data that's intermed, leave does like, you know, field A, field B, field C, then field A, field B, filled C. And there's a very common. And that's how you would for loop through it. It's, you know, how an LLM would write stuff by default. But understanding when and where, sometimes you want to rotate to a structure of arrays where you say, I have all my A channels together, all my Bs together, and then all my Cs together is a huge unlock in some cases for doing things like in SimD and other
最常见的就是使用结构体数组（Array of Structures），对吧？你有一个数组，在数组里放入交错的数据，比如字段 A、字段 B、字段 C，然后又是字段 A、字段 B、字段 C。这非常普遍。这也是你遍历数组的方式。这是大语言模型默认编写代码的方式。但理解何时以及在何处，有时你想要转变为结构体数组（Structure of Arrays），即把所有的 A 通道放在一起，所有的 B 放在一起，然后所有的 C 放在一起，这在某些情况下对于实现 SIMD 和其他
optimizations. And a lot of times, if you don't know that's possible, you don't know to dig into it. And there are lots of libraries. But again, compilers can do some SIMD, but there's only so much range they can act in, right? So they won't re-factor,
优化来说是一个巨大的提升。很多时候，如果你不知道这种可能性，你就不会去深入研究。虽然有很多库，但再说一次，编译器可以做一些 SIMD 优化，但它们能发挥的范围有限，对吧？所以它们不会为了获得 SIMD 优化而重构
they won't recompile your whole program in order to get SIMD optimization. And similarly, I think by analogy, even in the LMs, I think this is where, at least for today, I'll say, I think understanding to ask for it, because it's not something that it's going to know to reach for immediately.
整个程序。同样地，我认为通过类比，即使是在大语言模型中，我认为这就是为什么至少在今天，我认为理解去要求它进行这种优化很重要，因为它不会自动想到去使用这种方法。
And it's also trying to which we all want, you know, we don't want them spending extraneous tokens just doing constant refactoring and trying stuff except when we do. But like, you know, they're trying to limit it. So doing massive refactors like this and not knowing is,
而且它也在尝试——这也是我们都想要的——我们不希望它们浪费额外的 Token 去进行持续的重构和尝试，除非我们确实需要。但你知道，它们在试图限制这一点。所以进行这种大规模的重构，如果不知道自己在做什么，
so sometimes you're going to need to push it to say, look, I want to implement some de-optimization. I want you to build it in this way. And when and how to ask for that and whether it even makes sense is something you really got to think about. What hardware are you running on? And these are things,
所以有时你需要推动它，说：“看，我想实现 SIMD 优化。我希望你用这种方式构建它。”何时以及如何提出这种要求，以及它是否合理，是你真正需要考虑的事情。你在什么硬件上运行？这些都是，
I'll say, normally doesn't figure it out. Like, you normally have to tell it, you know, like, hey, you know,
我会说，大语言模型通常无法自己弄清楚。你通常必须告诉它，你知道，比如，“嘿，你知道，”
I want you, you know, write a simple, like I was doing something with the, just like a cheesy ML something. And it was like trying to run Kuda stuff. And I don't have GPU that's in video like on my door. It's like,
“我想要你，你知道，写一个简单的，就像我正在用一个蹩脚的机器学习东西做点什么。”它当时试图运行 CUDA 相关的东西。但我并没有 NVIDIA 的 GPU。它就像是，
why are you like stop? No, like you didn't even think to check it. So anyway, SimD is a very powerful tool. See our previous episode. See this blog article. but just I think to talk about how useful SIMT is and a very efficient thing and the instruction
“你为什么……停下？不，你甚至没想过要检查一下。”总之，SIMD 是一个非常强大的工具。请参阅我们之前的剧集。请参阅这篇博客文章。但我认为，谈论 SIMD 有多有用以及它是一种非常高效的东西，而且指令
sets have gotten better over time from when I first use them to now they're really kind of awesome and libraries use them but also as a means to back into talking to I think this is the kind of understanding it still is important to have because I think it's something where we still need to help give direction to what we want out of our programs. Yeah this is a good point you know I think that the LLMs, they make a lot of category errors. And by that I mean, just quick recap, five second on what a category error is. The common example is you give a student, you give a child, a tour of a university. And you say, here's like the math building, here's the computer science building, here's the literature building. And then the student says, well, where's the university
集随着时间的推移已经变得越来越好，从我第一次使用它们到现在，它们真的很棒，而且库也在使用它们。但这也是一个切入点，我认为这种理解仍然很重要，因为我认为我们仍然需要为我们想要从程序中得到的东西提供指导。是的，这是一个很好的观点，你知道，我认为大语言模型会犯很多范畴错误（Category Errors）。我的意思是，简单回顾一下，花五秒钟解释什么是范畴错误。常见的例子是，你带一个学生，带一个孩子，参观一所大学。你说，这是数学楼，这是计算机科学楼，这是文学楼。然后学生说，那么大学楼在哪里？
building. And it's like, well, no, the university is like an abstraction. That's like, you know, a collection of these physical buildings. It's not a building itself, right? So that's a category error. And I've noticed the AI is, a lot of these AIs really struggle when it comes to categorization. So for example, you know, you'll tell an AI, make this code faster. And what you really want is for it to, you know, find the hot spot. and rewrite them in SIMD. But what it actually does is like delete like the slow parts of your code and now it's not functional or or you know rewrites the whole thing in Rust or something like that.
这就好比，不，大学是一个抽象概念。它是一系列物理建筑的集合。它本身不是一栋建筑，对吧？所以这就是一个范畴错误。我注意到人工智能，很多这类人工智能在分类方面真的很挣扎。例如，你会告诉人工智能，“让这段代码运行得更快。”你真正想要的是让它找到热点（Hot spot），并用 SIMD 重写它们。但它实际做的是删除你代码中缓慢的部分，结果代码无法运行，或者它用 Rust 把整个程序重写了一遍之类的。
Like it rewrites the entire program, right? So it's like it doesn't know at what category at what level to operate. And so this is I think, you know, people, people use a term taste. I think taste is something different. but I think independent of taste, I think knowing at what category you need to operate to solve the problem you're trying to solve is still kind of firmly
就像它重写了整个程序，对吧？所以它不知道应该在什么范畴、什么层面上进行操作。所以我认为，你知道，人们使用“品味”（Taste）这个词。我认为品味是另一回事。但我觉得撇开品味不谈，我认为知道为了解决你试图解决的问题，需要在什么范畴内进行操作，仍然牢牢地
in the realm of human beings. And so you have to know that, hey, here's an option. You know, if you have this Python code, you know, one option you can do is to take the slow parts of the code and use Scython, you know, to bring them into C,
属于人类的领域。所以你必须知道，嘿，这是一个选项。你知道，如果你有这段 Python 代码，一个你可以做的选择是提取代码中缓慢的部分，并使用 Cython，你知道，将它们引入 C，
and then use SimD after that, as opposed to like rewriting the entire thing. I think it's time for Book of the Show. I've got the first book. This is a book I have and am getting ready to start reading. So unfortunately, I can't give the full review yet. But this is Waves in an Impossible Sea by Matt Strassler. And this is a book that's, I don't know how you call it.
然后在那之后使用 SIMD，而不是重写整个东西。我想是时候进行“本期图书”环节了。我有第一本书。这是一本我拥有并准备开始阅读的书。所以很遗憾，我还不能给出完整的书评。但这本书是马特·斯特拉斯勒（Matt Strassler）的《不可能海洋中的波浪》（Waves in an Impossible Sea）。这是一本，我不知道该怎么称呼它。
We've talked about some of these books number four. They have a name. It's slipping in my mind now. where it's like sort of a casual read, sort of like just a compelling story, but talking about facts. So I think Simon Singh does this for like, Fermat's Last Theorem and the code book cryptography book
我们之前讨论过一些这类书。它们有一个名字。我现在想不起来了。就是那种比较随意的读物，有点像是一个引人入胜的故事，但讨论的是事实。我认为西蒙·辛格（Simon Singh）在《费马大定理》和密码学书籍《码书》中就是这样做的，
where it's like stories, but through the stories, he's explaining like the history and the operation of something in sort of like layman's terms or whatever. Anyway, so this is that about sort of subatomic physics. And I do not know why through my entire life, I've just been sort of like fascinated by elementary particles, subatomic physics, even though like it's not my background. I never ended up studying it.
通过故事，他用通俗易懂的语言解释了某些事物的历史和运作方式。总之，这本书是关于亚原子物理学的。我不知道为什么我一生中一直对基本粒子、亚原子物理学着迷，尽管这不是我的专业背景。我最终从未研究过它。
I know really nothing about it. I won't talk about it because I'll like horribly screw it up. But just like the way that people describe, there's a couple of YouTube channels where people talk about like the sort of math and physics behind sort of like discoveries. You know, wise spectrographic lines were, you know, befuddling people in the early times. 20th century. Just like all these things. And I don't know. It just always really excites me. So I'm, I'm happy to dig into this book and just sort of like go on an adventure because for whatever reason, this domain has always, is a nonfiction. I guess I should clarify. It has always been something that is awesome. There's so much more going around at like the very, very small level that
我真的对它一无所知。我不会谈论它，因为我会把它搞得一团糟。但就像人们描述的方式，有几个 YouTube 频道，人们谈论发现背后的数学和物理。你知道，为什么光谱线在 20 世纪早期让人们感到困惑。就像所有这些事情。我不知道。它总是让我非常兴奋。所以我很高兴能深入阅读这本书，去进行一次冒险，因为无论出于什么原因，这个领域一直——这是一本非虚构类书籍，我想我应该澄清一下。它一直都是很棒的东西。在极小尺度上还有很多事情在发生，而
we kind of just never think about. And it's kind of crazy. But it's cool at the same time. So is this a fictional tale that explains a real phenomenon or is it a nonfiction book? It's a nonfiction book. It's not like an allegory or something. It's just a sort of talk through in an engaging narrative way through the history and state of these things. Oh, very cool. Yeah, I mean, I have just been diving into so many research papers that are not big. fairly interesting to me and my friend grew, my colleagues.
我们从来没有想过。这有点疯狂。但同时也很酷。所以这是一个解释真实现象的虚构故事，还是一本非虚构类书籍？这是一本非虚构类书籍。它不是寓言之类的东西。它只是以一种引人入胜的叙事方式，梳理了这些事物的历史和现状。哦，太酷了。是的，我的意思是，我一直在深入研究很多对我来说相当有趣的非大型研究论文，我的朋友和同事也是。
So I'm not going to make everyone suffer through the list of research papers I've been reading. But one of them in particular I wanted to talk about. So, okay, when we started with natural language processing with neural nets, right, people started with these recurrent neural nets. And so the idea is think about like a memory, a block of memory. but instead of it's storing very explicit things, like if you were to store the word dog in memory using Python or something, it would be a byte for the letter D, a bite for letter O, bite for large-g, and now you have dog, right?
所以我不会让大家忍受我一直在阅读的研究论文列表。但我特别想谈谈其中一篇。好的，当我们开始用神经网络进行自然语言处理时，对吧，人们是从循环神经网络（RNN）开始的。所以这个想法是，想象一个内存，一块内存。但它存储的不是非常具体的东西，比如如果你要用 Python 或其他语言在内存中存储“dog”这个词，它会是字母 D 的一个字节，字母 O 的一个字节，字母 G 的一个字节，现在你有了“dog”，对吧？
But instead of that, it's this really abstract, really high-dimensional space where you're storing, you know, a whole library full of concepts, and then you can sort of pop things off of that. So, you know, the early Transformers did this where you had an, encoder that took what the user is asking for and the, you know, partial answer, which could be nothing at the beginning, right, encoded it into, you know, this memory bank, and then a decoder that popped off, you know, tokens off the memory bank and then also updated it. So, so the idea is,
但它不是那样的，它是一个非常抽象、非常高维的空间，你在其中存储了，你知道，一整个图书馆的概念，然后你可以从中提取东西。所以，早期的 Transformer 就是这样做的，你有一个编码器（Encoder），它接收用户想要的东西和部分答案（开始时可能什么都没有），对吧，将其编码到这个内存库中，然后一个解码器（Decoder）从内存库中弹出 Token，并更新它。所以，这个想法是，
you know, user input comes in, typically not with a partial answer. So the user input comes in. It gets encoded in this memory bank. And then there's just this really tight loop. It's like, based on the memory bank, pop off, you know, the first word of the answer, and then mutate the memory bank, and then ask it again, and just keep popping words off the memory bank until you pop the end of answer word, which is like this special token, right? And so the problem with that is that you have to compress your question into this memory bank, right? And then as you're popping words off, the memory bank, you're also kind of having to store what you've popped off so far. So if you say, what is the capital of France that has to get crushed into this vector, right, that represents that question.
你知道，用户输入进来了，通常没有部分答案。所以用户输入进来了。它被编码在这个内存库中。然后就是一个非常紧密的循环。就像是，基于内存库，弹出答案的第一个词，然后改变内存库，然后再问一次，就这样一直从内存库中弹出单词，直到你弹出“答案结束”这个词，它就像是一个特殊的 Token，对吧？所以问题在于，你必须把你的问题压缩到这个内存库中，对吧？然后当你弹出单词时，你还得存储你目前已经弹出的内容。所以如果你说，“法国的首都是什么”，那必须被压缩成这个代表该问题的向量，对吧？
And then if you pop off, you know, the capital is, now that same memory bank has to know your question and know that you've already completed part of the answer. And this is why early transformers would do things like, the capital is, is, is, is, is, is, because it couldn't figure out how to store the fact that it's already said that word, right? And so now transformers are decoder only, which means they
然后如果你弹出“首都是”，现在同一个内存库必须知道你的问题，并且知道你已经完成了部分答案。这就是为什么早期的 Transformer 会做一些事情，比如“首都是，是，是，是，是，是”，因为它无法弄清楚如何存储它已经说过那个词的事实，对吧？所以现在 Transformer 都是仅解码器（Decoder-only）的，这意味着它们
what goes in is the question and you know the part of the answer you have so far and what comes out is a single word so like what is the capital
输入的是问题和你目前拥有的部分答案，输出的是一个单词。所以就像“法国的首都是什么”
of France what comes out is the and then this whole thing starts again so like all that work went in just to say the word the and then start the whole process over again
输出的是“the”，然后整个过程再次开始。所以所有的工作都只是为了说出“the”这个词，然后重新开始整个过程。
you know what is the capital of France the and then goes through this whole process and then outputs the word capital, right? And then so on and so forth. So now they've used KV cache and a whole bunch of tricks so that this doesn't waste that much computation, but it's still pretty weird, right? I mean, as a human being, I don't think we really operate this way.
你知道，“法国的首都是什么”，“the”，然后经历整个过程，然后输出“capital”这个词，对吧？以此类推。所以现在他们使用了 KV Cache 和一大堆技巧，这样就不会浪费太多计算量，但这仍然很奇怪，对吧？我的意思是，作为一个人类，我不认为我们真的是这样运作的。
I think, yeah, we internalize the question and then we sort of roll out the answer. So we've kind of deviated from the way a normal person or the way we expect a brain to think and reason. And it's pretty unnatural, right? So people are constantly trying to go back to this encoder-decoder idea. And world models have to be encoder decoder just because of their nature. We talked about world models on the last episode. And so the question is like why, how can you encode these things better so that you don't have to do that really expensive thing that we said earlier?
我想，是的，我们内化了问题，然后我们梳理出答案。所以我们已经偏离了正常人或我们期望大脑思考和推理的方式。这很不自然，对吧？所以人们一直在试图回到这种编码器-解码器（Encoder-Decoder）的想法。世界模型必须是编码器-解码器的，仅仅因为它们的本质。我们在上一集讨论过世界模型。所以问题是，如何更好地编码这些东西，这样你就不必做我们刚才提到的那种非常昂贵的事情？
and I think part of it is, you know, the memory is flat, right? And so on your computer, you know, when you do malloc or something like that, and you get a flat block of memory, you can then go and put an image in it. Because, you know, you're storing some metadata. And as a programmer, you always understand. The code is an easy way to remember, oh, this huge chunk of, this huge line of memory. is actually a 2D image. But I don't think that the LLM internal is really good at that.
我认为部分原因是，你知道，内存是扁平的，对吧？所以在你的电脑上，你知道，当你执行 malloc 或类似操作时，你得到一块扁平的内存，然后你就可以把一张图片放进去。因为，你知道，你在存储一些元数据。作为程序员，你总是明白。代码是一种简单的记忆方式，哦，这大块的、这长长的内存行，实际上是一张 2D 图片。但我不认为大语言模型的内部真的很擅长这一点。
And so I think what we actually need are, you know, two-dimensional, three-dimensional, like n-dimensional hypercubes of information that they can read and write to instead of just a line of information. And so this paper kind of talks about that. So this is a paper where instead, of a single line of data that you can write to, you can now write to a grid or a hypercube,
所以我认为我们真正需要的是二维、三维，甚至是 n 维的信息超立方体（Hypercubes），它们可以读写，而不是仅仅是一行信息。所以这篇论文谈到了这一点。这是一篇论文，其中不再是你可以写入的单行数据，你现在可以写入一个网格或超立方体，
and the space kind of matter. So if you write something to the left side of the cube, and then you write something else to the right side of the cube, those two locations are far apart, and it actually matters. It makes it harder for them to affect each other. So, yeah, so they basically are using, in this case, diffusion. Other people have used convolution. There's a bunch of different ways to do it. But I think that
空间是有意义的。所以如果你把东西写在立方体的左侧，然后把别的东西写在立方体的右侧，这两个位置相距很远，这实际上很重要。这使得它们更难相互影响。所以，是的，他们基本上在这种情况下使用了扩散模型（Diffusion）。其他人使用了卷积（Convolution）。有很多不同的方法可以做到这一点。但我认为
storing information this way is going to unlock something really powerful in LLMs and a world model. So it feels like there's something cool here. We're just kind of on the cusp of it. That's exciting. Yeah. It feels like there's this plate, but it hasn't been true almost where like traditional, I think there's on the output of LMs, like this DSPY sort of like, instructions and things like that for attempting to kind of get to it, but almost where like you're talking about like memory storage or whatever, it's like tool, very limited tool invocation within the, you know, actual inference itself, right? It's like know that you can put stuff here in this way rather than just like learning it completely. But, you know, that complication becomes
以这种方式存储信息将会在大语言模型和世界模型中解锁一些非常强大的东西。所以感觉这里有一些很酷的东西。我们正处于它的边缘。这很令人兴奋。是的。感觉就像有这个板块，但几乎还没成真，就像大语言模型的输出，像这种 DSPY 之类的指令，试图达到某种程度，但几乎就像你谈论的内存存储一样，它就像工具，在实际推理本身中非常有限的工具调用，对吧？就像知道你可以以这种方式把东西放在这里，而不是完全学习它。但是，你知道，那种复杂性变得
incredibly difficult. So, you know, it is definitely exciting though for them to figure it out themselves and potentially even a better way of doing it, I guess, then maybe naively we would make tools to do it. Yeah, totally, totally. All right, time for tool of the show. Patrick, what's your tool? This is a very, no, I'm just kidding. I was going to try to make it funny, but it's the same every time.
极其困难。所以，你知道，它们自己弄清楚这一点，甚至可能比我们天真地制造工具来做这件事有更好的方法，这绝对是令人兴奋的。是的，完全同意。好了，到了“本期工具”环节。帕特里克，你的工具是什么？这是一个非常……不，我开玩笑的。我本来想让它变得有趣，但每次都一样。
It's a game. This game is available on mini platforms, a PC phone. I think it was popular for a little while. I'm probably past it, but I think I picked it up on a sale, and it is Nubby's number factory, which, like, the game is pretty good. Like, I got pretty into it. I like it.
这是一个游戏。这个游戏可以在很多平台上玩，PC、手机。我想它流行了一段时间。我可能已经过了那个阶段，但我认为我是打折时买的，它是《Nubby's Number Factory》，这个游戏相当不错。我玩得很投入。我喜欢它。
It's a very casual. I think it's called like a Plinko-like, uh, rogue-like. Okay. Is that where you drop a thing and it pings off the, yeah, yeah, exactly. Yes, pings off numbers. Uh, you try to make number bigger.
这是一个非常休闲的游戏。我想它被称为类似 Plinko 的 Roguelike 游戏。好的。就是你扔下一个东西，它会弹来弹去的那种？是的，是的，没错。是的，在数字上弹来弹去。你试图让数字变大。
And then there's various power-ups and that are randomly chosen. And, you know, your exponential growth in the, what you need to hit at each level makes it very hard, and very careful. There's not a lot of skill to it, I would say. I mean, like a little bit, but that's not the kind of main point. But the aesthetics are trip.
然后有各种随机选择的强化道具。而且，你知道，你在每一关需要达到的指数级增长使得它非常困难，非常小心。我觉得它没什么技术含量。我的意思是，有一点，但那不是重点。但美学风格很棒。
It's like a trip down 90s, you know, Web 1.0, I guess I was like late 90s. Like, it's so good. Just like, you know, just I just pull up a screenshot of it. And if you'll know instantly if it's like, this is my jam or not. So for that reason alone, just like, I don't know, decent gameplay, but incredible art aesthetics.
就像回到了 90 年代，你知道，Web 1.0，我想是 90 年代末。太棒了。就像，你知道，我刚调出一张它的截图。如果你看一眼，你立刻就会知道这是否是你的菜。所以仅凭这一点，你知道，不错的游戏玩法，但令人难以置信的艺术美学。
But I mean horrible, but like amazing. It sounds like Bellotro as far as the gameplay. Yeah, I mean, same kind of idea. Like a very basic game, like you're trying to play poker hands, but then like it's scaling. So you have like it's really all about the power ups. Yeah. In that way, I guess it's kind of similar.
但我的意思是，虽然很糟糕，但很神奇。听起来游戏玩法和《Balatro》很像。是的，我的意思是，同样的思路。就像一个非常基础的游戏，你试图玩扑克牌，但它在扩展。所以你拥有的是，它完全是关于强化道具的。是的，从这个意义上说，我想它有点相似。
I mean, definitely it's not at the Bellotro level. I was watching people do like speed runs of Nan Inf like Belotro. Okay, that stuff's crazy. Oh my God, yeah, the Bellotro stuff. Yeah, I still haven't beaten Bellatro. Like, even in one deck, I haven't gotten through all the challenges. And then I watch these people and they're like, oh, yeah, I have one card. I play this one card and I just win.
我的意思是，它绝对没有达到《Balatro》的水平。我当时在看人们做《Balatro》的速通。好的，那些东西太疯狂了。天哪，是的，《Balatro》的东西。是的，我还没通关《Balatro》。就像，即使是一副牌，我也没完成所有的挑战。然后我看着这些人，他们说，哦，是的，我有一张牌。我打出这张牌，我就赢了。
But I found out a lot of them are apparently using various mods, like, and then, you know, saying they don't or just to make it like easier. They really want to play a certain card. So even the like when I was watching, which, you know, I trust him, I was like trying to get Nan E-Inf like very quickly. And so there's a certain card that they want in order to be able to do it. And so they were like doing a seeded run where they had searched for seeds that would guarantee that card comes up within like the first or second shop or something. And so they've never played that run before,
但我发现他们中的很多人显然在使用各种 Mod，然后，你知道，声称他们没有，或者只是为了让它更容易。他们真的很想玩某张特定的牌。所以即使是我在看的时候，（我信任他），我当时正试图非常快地达到“Nan E-Inf”。所以有一张特定的牌是他们想要的，为了能够做到这一点。所以他们是在进行种子局（Seeded run），他们搜索了能保证那张牌在第一或第二个商店出现的种子。所以他们以前从未玩过那局，
but they know like the card they want is going to be there. Got it. Interesting. I'm not saying everybody does that. I just like, it's more common than I realized. So yeah, the game's actually not that easy. We're being diluted. Well, I think there are people who just play it a ton, which is probably like,
但他们知道他们想要的牌会在那里。明白了。有趣。我不是说每个人都这样做。我只是觉得，这比我意识到的更普遍。所以是的，这个游戏其实没那么容易。我们被稀释了。嗯，我认为有些人只是玩得很多，这可能就像，
the same like Solitaire, like not all games of Solitaire are winnable. Yeah, it's probably like that. Like, I'm not saying not all games of Belatra are winnable, but some, you know, just you're going to have to play a certain amount of times in order to get 100% completion. And like, no matter how skilled you are. Yeah, that makes sense.
就像纸牌游戏（Solitaire），并非所有的纸牌游戏都是可赢的。是的，可能就是那样。就像，我不是说并非所有的《Balatro》游戏都是可赢的，但有些，你知道，你必须玩一定次数才能获得 100% 的完成度。无论你有多熟练。是的，这说得通。
makes sense my tool to show is open code and actually patrick earlier you talked about doing your taxes with an lLM okay i don't haven't done that no no not doing my taxes reviewing my taxes reviewing your taxes reviewing your taxes within lm the IRS is on their way it's like do too do Patrick open up um so i um okay so our tax accountant which is this really nice lady that We met through church a long time ago, retired. And so we had this debate in the household. I think that an L.L.M. could do my taxes. Oh, yes.
说得通。我的工具是 OpenCode，其实帕特里克，你刚才谈到了用大语言模型报税。好的，我没做过那个，不，不是报税，是审查我的税单。审查你的税单。用大语言模型审查你的税单。国税局（IRS）正在赶来的路上。就像，帕特里克，打开……嗯，所以我……好的，我们的税务会计师，是一位我们在很久以前通过教会认识的非常好的女士，退休了。所以我们在家里进行了这场辩论。我认为大语言模型可以帮我报税。哦，是的。
Yeah. And I'm the only person of family who thinks this. So I was like, okay, we'll do this. We'll have somebody do our taxes. and I will also do our taxes with an LLM and then we'll see if they match up or mine's better even, right? And if they match up or if it's even close, then we know that we're good.
是的。我是家里唯一一个这么想的人。所以我说，好吧，我们这样做。我们会找人帮我们报税，我也会用大语言模型来报税，然后看看它们是否匹配，或者我的甚至更好，对吧？如果它们匹配，或者即使很接近，那么我们就知道我们做得很好。
But similarly, I was thinking, you know, taxes, even like controlling the web browser where like all your cookies and your passwords are stored, like installing the Anthropic Chrome extension or having, you know, chatGBT do my taxes is where I draw the line. You know, like that's like, yeah. Like, and I feel like I'm pretty, you know,
但同样地，我在想，你知道，税收，甚至像控制网页浏览器，所有你的 Cookie 和密码都存储在那里，比如安装 Anthropic Chrome 扩展程序，或者让 ChatGPT 帮我报税，是我划定界限的地方。你知道，就像，是的。我觉得我在隐私方面相当，你知道，
open when it comes to privacy, but I feel like I draw the line at, you know, these kind of things. And so, and so I downloaded open code, which is one of many harnesses. I definitely don't claim that open code is better or worse than any of the other ones.
开放，但我感觉我在这些事情上划定了界限。所以，我下载了 OpenCode，它是众多工具包（Harnesses）之一。我绝对不声称 OpenCode 比其他任何工具更好或更差。
And maybe we should do, that could be a whole show, but I could do a deep dive on that. But at the moment, I'm trying OpenCode with these Muse and Quinn local models. And it's really, really good. As far as the harness goes, you can spin up subagents, you can do loops, which we'll talk about. All the things that you can do with Claude Code are pretty well supported with OpenCode. There is a little bit of jank. there was a situation where Muse, like,
也许我们应该做一期节目，那可以是一整期节目，我可以深入研究一下。但目前，我正在尝试用 Muse 和 Qwen 本地模型运行 OpenCode。它真的，真的很好。就工具包而言，你可以启动子代理（Subagents），你可以进行循环，我们稍后会谈到。Claude Code 能做的所有事情，OpenCode 都支持得很好。有一点点小毛病。有一种情况是 Muse，就像，
when it returned the tool response, it wasn't quite formatted correctly. And instead of, you know, dealing with that or retrying it, open code just hung indefinitely. And so I had to kill it. So it definitely got some jank. You know, got some jank.
当它返回工具响应时，格式不太正确。而不是，你知道，处理它或重试它，OpenCode 只是无限期地挂起了。所以我不得不杀掉它。所以它确实有一些小毛病。你知道，有一些小毛病。
But, you know, the fact that it's free and open source and works reasonably well, I think it's pretty nice. I ended up writing a very simple watchdog timer to kill open code if it's processing and it hasn't finished
但是，你知道，它是免费开源的，而且运行得相当好，我觉得这很不错。我最终写了一个非常简单的看门狗定时器（Watchdog timer），如果 OpenCode 在处理且在一定时间内没有完成，就杀掉它并重启。但再说一次，我认为这就像我们谈论 30B 模型时那样，我们可能距离拥有一个真正完善的东西还有六个月到一年的时间。
in a certain amount of time and restart it. But again, I think it's just like we talked about with the 30B models where we're maybe six months to a year away from having something
而 OpenCode，它似乎非常受欢迎。如果你想以非交互方式询问一堆代理问题，它有一个 Python SDK。所以总的来说，是一个非常强大的软件。另一个，我的意思是，就像你说的，我们会有一期节目讨论它，是 Pi 编码代理，它试图将工具包精简到
that's really polished here. And open code, it seems to be very popular. It's got a Python SDK if you want, want to non-interactively, you know, ask a bunch of agentic questions. So overall, really powerful piece of software. The other one, I mean, like you said, we would have an episode about it, but was the Pi coding agent, which tries to strip down the harness to
最低限度，然后让你添加你想要的东西。所以你要求 Pi 改进它自己，我觉得这非常有趣。我还没开始用，但它在我的候选名单上，所以我不知道像这样的东西是否可以用于，你知道，OpenCode，因为它的名字可能主要是为编码而构建的。所以如果你想把它用作多用途工具包，我不知道像这样的东西是否也能，你知道，起作用。是的，完全同意。是的，我非常想尝试 Pi。我听到了很多好消息。大约一周前我和某人一起吃午饭，他非常喜欢它，所以它绝对在名单上，所以我可以尝试一下，我们可以做一期节目。好的，听起来不错。
like kind of bare minimum and then have you add to it what you want. So you ask Pi to like improve itself, which I think is really interesting. I haven't gotten into it yet, but it's on my shortlists and so I wonder if something like that could be for you know open code by the name is probably built mostly for coding so if you wanted to use it as like a multi-purpose harness I wonder if something like that might you know also work yeah totally on the same page yeah I want to desperately try pie I've heard a lot of good things I went to lunch with somebody about a week ago who's really into it um so it's definitely on the list so I can try it and we can do a show on it Okay, all right, sounds good.
但你让我们悬着心。谁是对的？哦，好吧，珍妮特，你知道，我们的朋友，她实际上在一两周前退休了。所以这将是明年的税收。我可以进行回测。不过这是个好主意。也许我应该尝试做我当前这一年的，你知道，已经提交的那些。尝试在没有后见之明的情况下做。
But you left us hanging. Who was right? Oh, well, so Janet, you know, our friend, she retired literally like a week or two ago. And so this would be for next year's taxes. I could back test it. It's a good idea, though. Maybe I should try to do my current year, you know, the ones that were already submitted. Try to do that without hindsight.
这样我就不必等到一月或二月来尝试这个实验了。哦，我确实做了一件事，虽然有点相关，我下载了所有信用卡和支票账户等的 CSV 文件。所以我基本上得到了过去 90 天的所有交易数据。我通过 OpenCode 问 Muse，我说，嘿，给我一份我们的支出明细，我们在哪些方面花钱太多了？我们在哪里可以削减开支？诸如此类的事情。它做得相当不错。其实非常好，因为你知道，当大语言模型看到一张账单上只写着“Chili's”时，它知道 Chili's 是一家餐厅，对吧？那种东西，所以……
That way I wouldn't have to wait until January or February to try to. try this experiment out. Oh, one thing I did do, though, kind of related, I downloaded CSV files for all my credit cards and checking accounts and all that. So I got basically all my transaction data over the past 90 days. And I asked through OpenCode, I asked Mews, like, hey, give me a rundown of our expenses and what are we spending too much money on? Where can we cut down? Things like that. And it did a pretty good job. Actually, a really good job because you know that's when the LLMs are really good at if they see like a bill that just says Chili's it knows that Chili's is a restaurant right like that kind of stuff so so
这结果非常棒，所以我强烈推荐。我的意思是，也许甚至有一个开源项目之类的东西，人们可以安装一些桌面应用程序，我不知道它将如何连接到他们的银行，他们可能必须手动完成那部分，但一些桌面应用程序只是浏览他们所有的财务状况，你知道，对于那些在设置 OpenCode 等方面有困难的人来说。你在这里还有更多要说的，但好吧，让我们继续讨论我们的主题。好的，我们应该做一期关于，是的，自动财务管理的节目。
that actually turned out great so I'd highly recommend I mean maybe there's even something there around you know like a open source project or something where someone can just install some desktop app and I don't know how it would connect to their bank they'd probably have to do that part manually, but some desktop app that just like goes through all their finances and, you know, just for people who have a hard time setting up open code and all that. You have more to say here, but well, let's go ahead and go to our topic. All right. We should do a show on, yeah, automatic finance management.
但我们会做的。Brito efficient。Burrito。哦，伙计。我，你知道，我有这个。同样的 Twitter 账号用了 20 年左右，但我认为我需要改成 Pareto efficient（帕累托最优）。哦，伙计，太棒了。好的，代理循环（Agentic loops）。所以这里有一个历史课。所以现代历史。好的，当大语言模型刚出来时，当这项技术刚
But we will. Brito efficient. Burrito. Oh, man. I, it's, you know, I've had this. same Twitter handle for like, I don't know, 20 years or something, but I think I need to change into Pareto efficient. Oh, man, so good. All right, agentic loops. So a bit of a history lesson here. So modern history. Okay, when LLMs first came out, when the technology first
出来时，人们，公司害怕推出它。我不知道你是否记得那个时代，但绝对有一个时代，你知道，公司会试探性地接触聊天机器人，然后会有很多反弹。人们会找出它能说的最糟糕的话，最愚蠢的话，那会成为新闻头条。我特别记得的一个是 Facebook，我想它叫什么来着，叫 Liberatus 吗？我们得查一下。
came out, people, companies were afraid to roll it out. I don't know if you remember this era, but there was definitely an era where, you know, companies would dip their toe in the chat bot water and there would be so much backlash. People would find the worst possible thing that it could say, the dumbest thing it could say, and that would make the news headlines. The one I'm remembering of specifically was there was a Facebook, I think it was called, was it called Liberatus? We'd have to look this up.
但有一个 Facebook 项目，它可以创建研究论文。所以你会说，你知道，这是一堆相关工作。我希望你写一篇关于，你知道，空间神经网络之类的研究论文，对吧？然后它就会去写一篇五页的研究论文，看起来你可以直接提交给 ICML。所以人们写了荒谬的研究论文。比如，你知道，他们会写一篇关于用热狗运行计算机的研究论文，它真的会写出来，对吧？它不会反驳。
But there is this Facebook project where it would create research papers. So you would say, you know, here's a bunch of related work. I want you to write a research paper on, you know, spatial neural nets or something, right? And it would go off and write a five-page research paper that looked like you could submit it straight to ICML. And so people wrote ridiculous research papers. Like, you know, they would like write a research paper on running a computer, with hot dogs and it would do it, right? It wouldn't push back.
然后人们会提交它，不是提交给 ICML，而是提交给《纽约时报》之类的。就像，看看 Facebook 的机器人有多蠢。然后 Facebook 下架了它。他们很尴尬，他们把它撤下了。所以没人想发布聊天机器人。聊天机器人变得越来越好。
And then people would submit it, not submit it to ICML, but they'd submit to the New York Times or something. It's like, look how dumb the Facebook bot is. And Facebook pulled it down. They were embarrassed, they took it down. And so nobody wanted to release the chat bot. The chat bots kept getting better and better and better.
没人想按下绿色按钮，直到 OpenAI 按下了绿色按钮。当最初的 ChatGPT 出来时，他们受到了很多批评，对吧？就像，哦，这是邪恶的。它会教人们如何制造炸弹。它也是错的。它告诉你把胶水涂在披萨上吃掉，对吧？
Nobody wanted to press the green button until Open AI pressed the green button. And when the initial chat, GBT, came out, They got in so much, there's so much flack for it, right? It's like, oh, this is evil. It's going to teach people how to make bombs. It's also wrong. It's telling you to put glue on pizza and eat it, right?
所有这些事情。直到今天，你知道，每当你访问这些网站时，它告诉你的第一件事就是，你知道，Gemini 会犯错，对吧？ChatGPT 会犯错，对吧？我开车跟在一辆半挂车后面，它就像有时，你知道，自动驾驶车辆会犯错。我只是在开玩笑。哦，那太可怕了。但我们已经接受了这些模型会犯错的事实，对吧？即使它们不犯错，再说一次，还有范畴错误，你知道，它在技术上做了你想要的，但它没有遵循，你知道，普通人对那个问题所期望的那种精神，对吧？所以代理工程（Agentic engineering）就出现了。
All these things. And to this day, you know, whenever you go to any of these websites, the first thing it will tell you is, you know, Gemini makes mistakes, right? Chachu-T makes mistakes, right? I was driving behind a semi, and it's like sometimes, you know, the autonomous vehicle makes mistakes. mistakes. I'm just kidding about it. Oh, that's terrifying. But we just have come to terms with the fact that these models make mistakes, right? And even if they don't make mistakes, again, there's the category error where, you know, it did technically what you wanted, but it didn't follow kind of the spirit of what, you know, a common person would have expected, right, for that question. And so in comes agenetic engineering.
这个想法是，我们知道我们不会每次都做对。所以我们要做的就是把我们的答案反馈回去，看看是否还有更多工作要做，并一直这样做，直到我们得出某种结论。这就是，你知道，Claude Code 带入主流的东西，对吧？所以这一切都运作良好。但问题是，你什么时候停止？再说一次，之前所有的错误仍然存在。所以如果你可能会说，嘿，达到 90% 的单元测试覆盖率。
And the idea is we know we're not going to get it right every time. So what we're going to do is feed in our answer back in and see if there's more work to do and just keep doing this until we reach some kind of a conclusion. And that's what, you know, Claude Code kind of brought into the mainstream, right? So that all works out well. But the question there is when do you stop? And again, all of the same errors from before are still there. So if you might say something like, hey, get to 90% unit test coverage.
这是大约一年前的事了。因为循环的存在，现在不完全是这样了。但你会说达到 90% 的测试覆盖率。一年前，Claude Code 会写一些单元测试，然后说，嘿，我达到了 34%。这不是很棒吗？我要在这里停止，对吧？如果你想要 90%，你必须告诉它再做一次。我真的，大约一年前，有一个 Bash 循环，要求 Claude 在循环中达到 90% 的测试覆盖率，并运行了 24 小时才达到 90% 的测试覆盖率。所以这就是一个极其原始的代理循环，它奏效了。
And this is about a year ago. It's not really true now because of loops. But you'd say get to 90% test coverage. year ago and Claude code would write some unit tests and then say, hey, I got up to 34%. Isn't that awesome? I'm going to stop here, right? And if you wanted 90%, you had to tell it to do it again. And I literally, about a year ago, had a bash loop that asked Claude to get to 90% test coverage in a loop and just ran that for 24 hours to get to 90% test coverage. So that's, that's is an extremely primitive agentic loop that worked.
它是成功的。而现在，如果你说类似“达到 90% 的测试覆盖率”的话，Claude Code 会识别出你设定了一个目标，并将你的问题转换为一个循环。这就是它现在能够运行更长时间的原因。所以有时大语言模型会为你做这件事。通常它不会，而且再说一次，即使它做了，它也可能选择一个不符合你所想的那种精神的终止条件，对吧？如果你说类似“我想要这个模型的准确率提高”，嗯，那是什么意思？你想要它达到
It was successful. And nowadays, if you say something like gets a 90% test coverage, Quad code recognizes that you've set a goal and converts your question into a loop. And that's how it's able to run for much longer nowadays. So sometimes the LLM will do it for you. oftentimes it won't and and again even if it does it might choose a terminating condition that's not sort of in the spirit of what you are thinking of right if you say something like I want the I want the accuracy of this model to go up well like what does that mean do you want it to get to
90%？你想要它达到 99.9%？你知道，如果你让大语言模型决定这一点，那么你真的不知道你会从中得到什么。所以节目的其余部分，我们将讨论你可以如何构建，其他人是如何构建这些循环的，你可以如何构建这些循环以及其中的最佳实践。所以我认为，退后半步，
90% do you want it to get to 99.9% you know if you let the LM decide that then you don't really know you're going to get out of that. So the rest of the show, we're going to talk about how you can build, how other folks have built these loops, how you can build these kind of loops and best practices there. So I think for like a half step back,
我认为人们最早弄清楚的事情之一，这在 LangChain 和其他东西中很流行，除了 LangGraph。是的，是的。在那里，你想要，而且它只是一个循环，就像，你知道，拉取，监视电子邮件队列。
I think one of the earliest things people were figuring out, and this was popular with things like Lang chain and was other than laying grailgrath. Yeah, yeah. Where there were, you wanted to, and it's just kind of a loop, like, you know, pull, watch an email queue.
任何时候有客户服务问题进来，你都想标记它、分类它、分发它，你知道，无论什么，并推动它前进。对我来说，这就像变成了 Cron 任务。但这实际上是一个巨大的解锁，即，你知道，嘿，如果你有一个计算机系统，比如，醒来并时不时地问大语言模型这个网站上的价格是否发生了变化。
And anytime there's like a customer service question come in, you want to like label it, tag it, dispensate it, you know, whatever, and move it through. And I think for me, this just like turns into sort of like cron jobs. But it's actually a big unlock, which is, you know, hey, I, if you have a computer system, like, wake up and ask the LLM every so often if like the price on this, you know, website has changed.
你会说，哦，你可以为此写一个爬虫。是的，试着写一个爬虫，然后看着它失效，因为他们移动了东西，标签也变了，你知道，而不是给它一张截图，你知道，让它转换成文本，然后去做。这是一个大问题。所以只是回复重复发生的事件或做同样的任务，这再次，我认为这是在介绍之前的一个半步。但这确实是我们看到循环大语言模型接管的最早的地方之一。但随后过渡到更多，你知道，正如杰森所说，对我来说，那个循环中最大的一个，它就像人们总是谈论的拉尔夫·威格姆（Ralph Wiggum）循环。是的，他们就像，编写这个特殊技能之类的东西来一遍又一遍地做同样的事情。比如，你知道，挑选一个 Bug，然后，你知道，尝试修复那个 Bug，挑选下一个 Bug 并尝试修复那个 Bug。但第一个真正，我认为，随之走红的是安德烈·卡帕西（Andre Karpathy），他似乎有一种走红的天赋。
You're like, oh, you can write scrape. for that. Yeah, try to write a scraper and then just watch like it not work because they move the stuff and the tags change, you know, versus giving it a screenshot, you know, and having it converted to text and then doing it. This is like a big deal. And so just replying to recurring events or doing the same task, which again, I think it was a half step before, you know, the introduction. But this was like one of the earliest places where, you know, we saw like the looping LLM sort of take a over. But then to transition to more, you know, what Jason said, for me, the big one, this loop there was, it was like the Ralph Wiggum loop that people would always talk about. Yeah, where they were like, write this special skill or whatever to like do the same thing over and over again. Like, you know, pick a, you know, bug and, you know, try to fix that bug, pick the next bug and try to fix that bug. But the first one to really like, I think go, I'll say viral with it was Andre Carpathy, which feels like he has an act for going viral.
你会想，哦，你可以为此写一个爬虫。是啊，试着写一个爬虫，然后看着它失效，因为网站改版了，标签也变了，对吧？相比之下，给它一张截图，让它转换成文本，然后再处理，这意义重大。所以，仅仅是回复重复性事件或执行相同的任务，我认为这在介绍之前只是半步之遥。但这确实是我们看到循环LLM开始接管的最早场景之一。但转到Jason所说的，对我来说，最重要的一点是，那个循环就像人们常说的Ralph Wiggum循环。是的，他们会说，写这个特殊的脚本之类的东西来一遍又一遍地做同样的事情。比如，挑一个bug，试着修复它，再挑下一个bug，再试着修复它。但我认为第一个真正让它“病毒式传播”的是Andrej Karpathy，他似乎有一种让内容病毒式传播的天赋。
Or maybe only a survivorship bias. I'm not sure. I actually don't know how he says otherwise. But he did this thing where he posted something that he titled Auto Research. I'm not sure if it was from the beginning or he eventually titled it that. But where he took a very small, I think it was nano-GPT, which is like a small GPT on a set training set and said, you know, basically can you make this run faster, train faster? and can you try various fixes to improve the metric, the output performance?
或者可能只是幸存者偏差。我不确定。我其实不知道他怎么说，但他做了一件事，他发布了一个标题为“自动研究”的东西。我不确定这是从一开始就有的，还是他后来才这样命名的。他拿了一个非常小的模型，我想是 nano-GPT，就像在一个固定的训练集上的小型 GPT，然后说，你知道，基本上你能不能让它运行得更快、训练得更快？你能不能尝试各种修复方法来改善指标和输出性能？
And to Jason's point, the terminating condition wasn't really present, but just this desire to go again and again and try something and then revert, you know, if it didn't work or it made it worse. Now, of course, like, it went viral because it was hugely successful. But there are lots of gotchas along the way as well. Like, there may be you need two, three, four things combine. So, you know, you take a step back to take two steps forward, you know, like there are all of these places is you have to be very aware, you know, of what the problem scoping and what the domain is and how much least you're doing it. But I do think there's this, and we talked about a little earlier, like the tension between, especially a cloud
说到 Jason 的观点，终止条件其实并不明确，但就是这种不断尝试、不断重试的渴望，如果行不通或者情况变糟了，就回退。当然，它之所以走红是因为它非常成功。但这一路上也有很多陷阱。比如，你可能需要两、三个、四个东西结合起来。所以，你知道，你退一步是为了进两步，你知道，所有这些地方你都必须非常清楚问题范围是什么，领域是什么，以及你到底在做什么。但我确实认为存在这一点，我们之前也讨论过，比如在云端提供商之间存在这种张力，
LLM provider, not wanting to be accused of just evaporating your tokens. So therefore, they don't want loops that aren't going anywhere. And you who may be saying, like, I'm not paying the bill. I want all of it. And so, you know, you can end up with these tensions. And so specifying something almost external to even the harness or even a lot of these stuff is incredibly useful because then you're really crafting, sculpting, setting, trying it, encouraging, whatever you want to do and manipulating, you know, that prompt.
LLM 提供商不想被指责只是在消耗你的 token。因此，他们不希望出现没有进展的循环。而你可能会说，我不想付账单。我想要全部。所以，你知道，你最终可能会陷入这些张力中。因此，指定一些甚至在工具框架之外的东西，或者甚至很多这些东西，是非常有用的，因为这样你实际上是在精心制作、塑造、设置、尝试、鼓励，无论你想做什么，并操纵那个提示词。
And normally you would need a human sitting there. But actually, like, you can ask an LLM between runs, should, like, should we revert that? Does that, you know, make sense? Is there something further along those lines? You don't need the pre-planned complete trajectory to go down. And so I think this has really caught, you know, people's attention. And now, and I think this has been popular before, but now it feels within and reach just to kind of like the final maximal extent of this
通常你需要一个人坐在那里。但实际上，你可以在运行之间询问 LLM，我们应该回退吗？这有意义吗？沿着这些思路还有什么吗？你不需要预先规划完整的轨迹。所以我认为这确实引起了人们的注意。现在，我认为这以前就很流行，但现在感觉触手可及，只是达到这种最终的最大程度，
is when these allelims are, if they can, reach recursive self-improvement. So the idea is if one of these, you know, major AI providers or a new up-and-comer gets an AI that can improve itself by, you know, 10, 15% per training cycle, then they can basically just keep doing that without human intervention. And it's just bottlenecked by speed, compute, power, whatever, you know, and then they'll just be on a quote unquote escape velocity. I still think that makes a bunch of assumptions, but you'll hear it, you know, tossed around. You've heard. AGI, it kind of went by the wayside a little artificial general intelligence. But now you'll have this RSI, this recursive self-improvement where these loops are what is being done to try to say, can the LLM figure out what the LLM needs? And of course, the evil laughter one is, you know, hey, we need to make this thing more efficient. And then the robot decides the humans are the inefficiency. And so that annihilates all the humans because they're just consuming needless resources.
就是当这些大语言模型能够实现递归自我改进时。所以这个想法是，如果这些主要的 AI 提供商之一或一个新的后起之秀获得了一个可以自我改进的 AI，比如每个训练周期提高 10% 到 15%，那么他们基本上就可以在没有人类干预的情况下继续这样做。它只是受限于速度、计算能力等等，你知道，然后它们就会处于所谓的“逃逸速度”。我仍然认为这做出了很多假设，但你会听到它被提及。你听说过 AGI，它有点被边缘化了，即通用人工智能。但现在你会听到 RSI，即递归自我改进，这些循环就是为了试图弄清楚 LLM 是否能找出 LLM 需要什么。当然，邪恶的笑话是，嘿，我们需要让这个东西更有效率。然后机器人决定人类是低效的。所以它消灭了所有人类，因为他们只是在消耗不必要的资源。
But yes, that's the Terminator scenario, I guess. Yeah. Yeah, it's, it definitely lends itself to going off the rails. I mean, I think, like, leading up to this was this idea of in-context learning. There's actually a paper that just came out not that long ago, or somebody showed that if you add periods to the end of a question, question or to the end of a prompt that it actually get better answers. So, and the more periods you add, the better an answer you'll get.
但是的，我想这就是终结者场景。是的。是的，它绝对容易失控。我的意思是，我认为，导致这种情况的是上下文学习的想法。实际上有一篇论文不久前刚出来，有人展示了如果你在问题末尾或提示词末尾加上句号，它实际上会得到更好的答案。所以，你加的句号越多，得到的答案就越好。
And the explanation was, well, you know, every single period requires the model to have to spend more compute. And so that's just more opportunity for the model to think. And so you literally had this graph where it's like, it's like, you know, statistically significantly smarter if you just add more periods of that. the end. And so, so clearly like, you know, if you were to add instead of periods, but add, you know, useful, you know, auxiliary content or a failed experiment or something like that, then clearly it's going to be, you know, more intelligent of an answer. If periods do it, right, then useful information
解释是，好吧，你知道，每一个句号都需要模型花费更多的计算资源。所以这只是模型思考的更多机会。所以你真的有一个图表，显示如果你只是在末尾添加更多的句号，它在统计学上显著更聪明。所以，很明显，如果你添加的不是句号，而是有用的辅助内容或失败的实验之类的东西，那么显然它会得到更智能的答案。如果句号能做到，那么有用的信息
is going to do it even more. And so, and so that's sort of spawned this idea of, hey, like, you know, let's try something. And as long as you document your success. or failure, and that's going to result in a better answer next time. And, yeah, and so, you know, then you run into issues around the context limit and compaction and all of that. And so that's a whole other issue is how do you, how do you sort of give the right paper trail to these LLMs? That's maybe even another show.
会做得更好。所以，这催生了一个想法，嘿，让我们尝试一些东西。只要你记录下你的成功或失败，下次就会得到更好的答案。而且，是的，然后你会遇到关于上下文限制、压缩等等的问题。所以这是另一个问题，你如何给这些 LLM 提供正确的追踪记录？这可能又是另一期节目了。
but the first part of this is is kind of setting up, you know, appropriate terminating conditions and an appropriate way to step forward. So if you say, you know, hey, build Facebook. All right. If you just go into Claude Code and say, build Facebook,
但这一部分主要是为了设置适当的终止条件和适当的前进方式。所以如果你说，嘿，建立一个 Facebook。好吧。如果你只是进入 Claude Code 说，建立一个 Facebook，
well, you know, that's a very nebulous question. And probably what it's going to do is it's going to, you know, build a front end that looks a lot like Facebook and, and, and, and, you know, maybe a back end for, for doing some basic things, like posting messages and receiving them and all of that. But, you know, if you wanted, for example, live video, it's probably not going to build that feature, right?
好吧，你知道，这是一个非常模糊的问题。它可能会做的是，它会建立一个看起来很像 Facebook 的前端，以及一个用于做一些基本事情的后端，比如发布消息和接收消息等等。但是，如果你想要，例如，实时视频，它可能不会构建那个功能，对吧？
At least not in the first prompt, right? Now, on the flip side, if you set up a loop and you said, you know, build Facebook and then also like, you know, search the internet for like the top 100 most useful features in Facebook and go through all hundred of them and, you know, tell me which one of those has have been built and haven't been built and get to a hundred out of 100, right? well that's very different because now the model has an easy way of knowing whether it's completed the task or not so it'll go to the web it'll grab 100 features based off i don't know reddit or whatever people people are talking about their favorite facebook features um and uh and so the loop will will know based on trying out your program that only 70 of the features are done and it will continue and at that point it's pretty determined. So, you know, there's like,
至少在第一个提示词中不会，对吧？现在，另一方面，如果你设置了一个循环，你说，建立一个 Facebook，然后搜索互联网上 Facebook 最有用的 100 个功能，遍历所有 100 个功能，告诉我哪些已经构建了，哪些还没构建，并达到 100/100，好吧，那是非常不同的，因为现在模型有一种简单的方法知道它是否完成了任务，所以它会去网络上，根据 Reddit 或人们谈论他们最喜欢的 Facebook 功能的内容抓取 100 个功能，然后循环会根据尝试你的程序知道只有 70 个功能完成了，它会继续，在那一点上它是相当确定的。所以，你知道，有，
I've actually seen it where if it runs for too long, the harness will kill it and things like that. But generally speaking, if you give it a very easily verifiable target, you know, it will loop indefinitely to achieve that target. And there's things that you can do to make sure that it's committed, which we'll talk about. So there's kind of two categories of loops.
我实际上见过如果它运行时间太长，工具框架会杀死它之类的情况。但总的来说，如果你给它一个非常容易验证的目标，它会无限循环以实现该目标。你可以做一些事情来确保它被提交，我们稍后会讨论。所以循环大致分为两类。
So maybe three categories. One is sort of firing on a trigger. So, you know, a GitHub issue has come in, an email has come in, et cetera. There's sort of a cron, you know, firing every day every five minutes or 15 minutes. And then there's this third one where it's almost like a while loop where it's, you know, loop until a certain condition has been met. And so it's kind of like we're reinventing basic all over again. But we're doing it with a much more capable of instruction set. Yeah, I wonder.
也许是三类。一种是基于触发器触发。比如，GitHub 问题进来了，电子邮件进来了，等等。有一种是 Cron，每天每五分钟或 15 分钟触发一次。然后是第三种，它几乎就像一个 while 循环，即循环直到满足某个条件。所以这有点像我们重新发明了 BASIC。但我们使用的是能力强得多的指令集。是的，我想知道。
I feel chaining a lot of those things together is going to be really interesting. And I think, you know, obviously, there's lots of opportunity, but it's tough to build right now because in that space, you just don't know what will get scooped, what will get, you know, implemented by the major, major providers. But certainly I think that crafting very targeted directions and also doing some form of which I know you might have have some insight to but also like sort of space exploration, no, not like outer space, but sort of like exploring design space is something that I haven't
我觉得把很多这些东西串联起来会非常有趣。而且我认为，显然，有很多机会，但现在很难构建，因为在这个领域，你不知道什么会被抢先，什么会被主要提供商实现。但我当然认为，制定非常有针对性的方向，以及进行某种形式的——我知道你可能有一些见解——空间探索，不，不是外太空，而是探索设计空间，是我还没有
really seen a ton of progress towards. Like we talked about earlier sort of like, hey, you could please refactor this to use SMD. Right. It's like a very specific thing. But exploring that space in a like sensible way with you know sort of branching and picking up that's how humans or at least my brain ends up working you kind of like all of these potential things and you're sort of trying to balance the explore versus exploit in in the design space and that's not something that's something that's something that I still need to provide strongly but with loops and this is something that I think in the future as lower low low low smaller models get faster and faster and faster,
真正看到有大量进展的东西。就像我们之前讨论的，嘿，你可以重构这个以使用 SIMD。这是一个非常具体的事情。但以一种合理的方式探索那个空间，进行分支和选择，这就是人类，或者至少我的大脑工作的方式，你会有所有这些潜在的东西，你试图在设计空间中平衡探索与利用，这不是我仍然需要强烈提供的东西，但有了循环，我认为在未来，随着更小的模型变得越来越快，
there becomes a point where you can just, you know, shotgun approach, try all the things in parallel, and sort of like, you know, obviously explore very quickly, but then choosing which ones to pick up and continue or not, you know,
会有一个点，你可以直接采用“霰弹枪”方法，并行尝试所有事情，显然探索得非常快，然后选择哪些要采纳并继续，你知道，
yeah, I don't know. There are some interesting ways of approaching it. Yeah, I think actually that's a really good point. You know, we should talk about subagents. So,
是的，我不知道。有一些有趣的方法来处理它。是的，我认为这实际上是一个很好的观点。你知道，我们应该谈谈子代理。所以，
so a sub-agent, is basically, think of it as, it's basically recursion, right? So think of it as clod code spins up another clod code and asks it to do something. And so the nice thing about that is the sub-agent has its own context. So here's an example. If you are, let's say you're coding up Facebook, so I want to build Facebook. and the ux the the the the the ui doesn't look quite right so you know it's the the columns are too wide and you know the heading is too too thick and doesn't quite look like facebook well so you're going to
一个子代理，基本上，把它想成是递归，对吧？所以把它想成 Claude Code 启动了另一个 Claude Code 并要求它做某事。这样做的好处是子代理有它自己的上下文。这是一个例子。如果你正在编写 Facebook，我想建立一个 Facebook。而 UI 看起来不太对，所以列太宽了，标题太粗了，看起来不像 Facebook，所以你会
spend a ton of tokens going back and forth about that right you're going to say well you know go to the facebook dot com look at their website get their columns right and it's going to go to facebook dot com and take a screenshot, take a screenshot of your version, and each of those screenshots are going to be hundreds and hundreds of tokens, right? And you're going to hit your context limit comparing all these screenshots, and then it's going to do something called compaction. And what compaction does is it basically summarizes all of the content up until now. And, you know, it's sort of a black box, right? You can't really count on it to do anything you know, as you would expect.
花费大量的 token 来回讨论这个问题，对吧？你会说，去 facebook.com 看他们的网站，把列弄对，它会去 facebook.com 并截屏，截取你版本的屏幕，每一个截图都会是成百上千个 token，对吧？你会达到上下文限制，比较所有这些截图，然后它会做一些叫做压缩的事情。压缩基本上是总结到目前为止的所有内容。而且，这有点像黑盒，你不能指望它做任何你期望的事情。
So to compaction might just delete all those images, which is probably what you want, or it might keep them and like delete all the interesting design work you did before you went into this rabbit hole, which is what you don't want, and you can't count on one of the other. So you could say, you know, spin up a sub-agent and have that sub-agent in a loop,
所以压缩可能会删除所有这些图像，这可能正是你想要的，或者它可能会保留它们并删除你在进入这个兔子洞之前所做的所有有趣的设计工作，这正是你不想要的，你不能指望它做哪一个。所以你可以说，启动一个子代理，让那个子代理在一个循环中，
have that sub-agent compare visually, your site and the original Facebook site in a loop and iterate until it's complete. And so while that sub-agent is off doing that, you could even do other things. But concurrency aside, if nothing else, it manages the context. So when that sub-agent returns
让那个子代理在循环中直观地比较你的网站和原始 Facebook 网站，并迭代直到完成。所以当那个子代理在做这件事时，你甚至可以做其他事情。但撇开并发性不谈，至少它管理了上下文。所以当那个子代理返回时，
and it says, okay, I've got it visually, you know, a match, when it returns, all of that context is deleted, which is, in this case, what you want so that you can move on to the next thing without polluting the main context. And so if you use Git work trees or other sort of technology where multiple programs can edit the same code at the same time and basically have a whole Git workflow locally,
它说，好的，我在视觉上匹配了，当它返回时，所有这些上下文都被删除了，在这种情况下，这正是你想要的，这样你就可以继续做下一件事，而不会污染主上下文。所以如果你使用 Git 工作树或其他技术，多个程序可以同时编辑相同的代码，并且基本上在本地拥有整个 Git 工作流，
then you could spin up. You come up with 10 ideas to make my website more flashy. and here's this benchmark, here's this black box you can run that gives you a flashiness score. So come up with 10 ideas, have 10 sub-agents, do 10 totally different things
那么你可以启动。你想出 10 个让我的网站更炫酷的点子，这里有一个基准，这里有一个你可以运行的黑盒，它会给你一个炫酷分数。所以想出 10 个点子，有 10 个子代理，做 10 件完全不同的事情
to make the website flashy, and then, you know, tell me which of those 10 increase the flashiness score and then keep those and throw away the others. So you can start to get to this like simulated annealing kind of approach where you try a bunch of ideas, and keep the ones that are better. So I think we'll start to see a lot of this stuff
让网站变得炫酷，然后告诉我这 10 个中哪些提高了炫酷分数，然后保留那些，丢弃其他的。所以你可以开始采用这种模拟退火的方法，尝试一堆点子，并保留更好的那些。所以我认为我们将开始看到很多这样的东西
come to bear more formally. But right now you can build it yourself. Now I'm just thinking about Nubby's number factors flashingness score. I wonder if there's a way to quantify, you know, like how engaging something is. Because that's one thing, in LLM, I don't know if it can really,
更正式地出现。但现在你可以自己构建它。我现在只是在想 Nubby 的炫酷分数。我想知道是否有一种方法可以量化某样东西有多吸引人。因为这是一件事，LLM，我不知道它是否真的能，
could it look at that game, and the ET game on Atari and know that one is better than the other, you know, other than from just popular sense of it, right? Nobody could definitely hire people on Fiverr and do a poll. That's true. Oh, another thing that's worth of mentioning, we kind of wrap up here, but loops are early days.
它能看那个游戏，雅达利的 ET 游戏，并知道哪一个比另一个更好吗？除了大众的看法之外，对吧？Nubby 绝对可以雇人在 Fiverr 上做民意调查。那是真的。哦，还有一件事值得一提，我们在这里总结一下，但循环还处于早期阶段。
I mean, this is now the third time that I've mentioned this, so it does seem to be kind of like a trope for this episode, but kind of like 30B models, loops are early days. And so one thing that I've found is if I tell it, let's say the 90% test coverage case, sometimes it will just end. Like sometimes it won't respect your terminating condition. Sometimes the loop just ends and you don't know why and it's not really clear.
我的意思是，这是我第三次提到这一点，所以这似乎成了这一集的套路，但就像 30B 模型一样，循环还处于早期阶段。所以我发现的一件事是，如果我告诉它，比如 90% 的测试覆盖率案例，有时它会直接结束。有时它不会尊重你的终止条件。有时循环就结束了，你不知道为什么，也不清楚原因。
the one loop that the one loop that seems to be reliable is the Cron job and maybe that makes sense right because it's the least ambiguous so if you say run something every five minutes it will almost certainly run every five minutes indefinitely so what I've learned to do is I have something
唯一看起来可靠的循环是 Cron 作业，也许这说得通，因为它最不模棱两可。所以如果你说每五分钟运行一次，它几乎肯定会无限期地每五分钟运行一次。所以我学会了做的是，我有一些东西
that says hey monitor this run like train a model monitor the metrics of the model and you know if the model is better then put it in this cat in this folder full of really great models if the models are regression then abandon it right and sometimes that loop will work and sometimes it'll just stop they'll say oh yeah i trained i trained my third model i'm done and it's actually not done right so i've set up another loop which runs in parallel which basically says you know wake up every 15 minutes and if if this other
说，嘿，监控这次运行，训练一个模型，监控模型的指标，如果模型更好，就把它放在这个装满很棒模型的文件夹里，如果模型是回归的，就放弃它。有时那个循环会工作，有时它会停止，它会说，哦，是的，我训练了我的第三个模型，我完成了，但实际上它并没有完成。所以我设置了另一个并行运行的循环，它基本上说，每 15 分钟醒来一次，如果这个循环停止了，就重新启动它。拥有这两个循环似乎是防止第一个循环死亡的一种方法。我本来想开个玩笑说我们是循环中的子代理，但我的循环卡住了。显然我们没有另一个每两周踢我们一次来制作一集的代理。我们需要一个，那是代理。那是我们缺少的。嗯，但也许只是一个行动号召。我的意思是，过去一个月我用循环做了很多事情。正如我所说，我已经让播客在本地用本地 LLM 免费转录并完成所有这些工作。还有很多其他项目，MAME Hub 的事情，它现在直接去做了。
loop has stopped than just, you know, started again. And, uh, and having both of those loops seems to be, uh, a way to like keep that first one, you know, uh, from dying. I was going to crack a joke about us being sub agents in the loop, but, uh, my loop got stuck. Apparently we don't have the other agent that kicks us every two weeks to make an episode. We need a, that's the agent. That's, we're missing. Um, But maybe just like a, you know, kind of a call to action here. I mean, I've done so much with loops in the past month. As I said, I've kind of gotten the podcast to transcribe and do all of that stuff locally with local LLMs for free. So many other projects, the MAME Hub thing, where it just goes off and does its thing now.
这是一种超级、超级、超级强大的技术。强烈建议大家学习并利用它。但它也很简陋。它还处于早期阶段。早期阶段实际上是最好的日子。事后看来，当所有这些东西都解决了，并且有点冻结了，我们都在使用它时，它就变得没那么有趣了。我的意思是，在这一点上，你有机会真正塑造这些东西最终的样子。
It's a super, super, super powerful technology. highly recommend folks learn it and leverage it. But it's also, it's just janky. It's just early days. Early days are actually kind of the best days. In hindsight, you know, when all of this stuff is solved and kind of frozen and we're all just using it, it becomes a little bit less interesting. I mean, at this point, you have a chance to actually shape the way that these things end up.
所以如果你没有使用循环，你一定要学习它。所以人们走得更远，做了图。基本上是许多不同代理之间的这种通信协议。我的意思是，我认为这正在成为做这件事的更有效的方法。但无论如何你打字不多。所以如果你有三个循环，目前可能没问题。但是的，绝对是你应该关注的东西。这个领域发展太快了。
So definitely if you're not using loops, you should learn it. So people have gone further and done grass. and basically this whole like, you know, communication protocol between many different agents. And I mean, I think that this is becoming like maybe more efficient ways of doing this. But you're not really typing that much anyways. So if you have like three loops, it's probably fine at this point in time. But yeah, definitely, you know, something that you should keep your eye on. This space is moving so fast.
我不知道。我觉得我们应该讨论一些话题，而不是像积压工作那样，哦，几年前有人建议过这个。我觉得我们正处于这种发展发生的阶段。我们应该谈谈它。是的。是的，太疯狂了。我的意思是，我绝对认为我们应该涵盖 Pie。
I don't know. I feel like there are topics for us to discuss instead of like the backlog, like, oh, someone suggested this a few years ago. I feel like we're in this stage of like this development happens. We should talk about it. Yeah. Yeah, it's wild. I mean, I definitely think we should cover pie.
我实际上安装了它，但我没有用它做太多事情。我把它写在我的便利贴上了。我要去做了。不错。做点有成效的事。是的，是的。所以各位，如果你遇到了技术，无论是工具框架还是任何你觉得我们应该引起听众注意的东西，给我们发电子邮件，在 Discord 上联系我们。一如既往，非常感谢你们在 Patreon 和其他平台上的所有支持。
I actually have it installed, but I haven't done a whole lot with it. I wrote it on my sticky. I'm going to go do it. Nice. And do something productive. Yeah, yeah. So folks out there, if you are coming across tech, you know, whether it's harnesses or really anything that you feel like we should bring to attention to the audience, just shoot us an email, hit us up on Discord. And as always, thank you so much for all of your support on Patreon and the other platforms.
我们下次再见。音乐由 Eric Barn Dollar 创作。根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音和改编，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
And we will catch you all next time. Music by Eric Barn Dollar. distributed under a Creative Commons attribution share-a-like 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work to remix and adapt the work but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share like and kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下次再见。音乐由Eric Barn Dollar创作。根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，也可以重混和改编作品，但必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。